the body of an Obama staffer was found
on the Obama's property this is their
chef it is presumed to be an accident
but this story is big and of course the
conspiracy theories are already coming
out but uh you know we don't need to
entertain the uh uh the actual
conspiracies but we can talk about them
at the very least and uh just generally
give you the news on the story because
it actually is really really big people
are wondering what happened how it
happened and uh why his Chef was
presumably paddle boarding in a pond
near his estate we got other really big
news this one's crazy uh Twitter is gone
it is now X there's still remnants of
Twitter the app is still called Twitter
in many places but on the actual website
in the browser version the Twitter bird
is gone it's an X now and they're slowly
changing these uh the title many of the
employees are now saying ax instead of
Twitter Elon Musk says they're another
called tweets they're called X which
just doesn't work you can't speak it so
I don't know whose plan is there but uh
exciting stuff nonetheless he's gonna be
transforming Twitter into the everything
app which has horrifying implications if
you ask me considering the AI that
they're gonna be integrating I do think
there's a lot of good income from this I
do generally like what Elon Musk does
but it's going to get interesting and
then we've got a whole bunch more news
new evidence implicating Joe Biden uh
being on phone calls according testimony
from Devin Archer with with Hunter and
Hunter's Associates so okay and then
we've got store a story coming about a
man who has I guess super Covenant
they're calling it MERS and some people
believe this could be what leads to
another lockdown who knows an election
is coming up so we will get into all of
that but my friends before we do head
over to caskbrew.com foreign coffee join
the cast Brew Coffee Club you'll get
three bags every single month or you can
just choose these different varieties we
have rise with Roberto Jr it's a light
roast breakfast blend Appalachian nights
at dark roast Colombian and French roast
and they are all available in ground or
whole bean just click them and then make
your selection I gotta tell you my mom
says that Appalachian nights is the best
and that means a lot so you should buy
it but if you want to support us we're
sponsoring ourselves when you buy Casper
coffee not only are you supporting
everything we do because this is you
know it's our product but you're helping
us we are launching physical coffee
shops most of you know this already and
uh hopefully in a few months we will
have our first location open but we'll
see and then from there we want to
create physical spaces people can hang
out and interact and that's the next
step in winning a culture War but don't
don't forget also become a member at
timcast.com by clicking join us we will
have a members only uncensored show at
10 pm tonight after we wrap up the live
public portion of the show we do a live
uncensored where you the guests actually
call in and talk to us and and our guest
you the viewer sorry the viewers can
call in and talk to us just become a
member at the 25 per month level you can
submit your questions or if you've been
a member at any level for at least six
months you can submit your questions and
potentially be one of our callers so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends I'm back joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is Dave
Lando hey how are you sir I'm really
great actually good all patched up
that's what I heard you got went down to
Mexico I went down to Tijuana and they
fixed up your hip yeah they just take
one kidney yeah only one that's awesome
which is good fair trade I ended up
getting spared to surgery this is
fantastic shout out to the cellular
performance Institute y'all may have
heard of them on Joe Rogan Eddie Bravo
was talking about it and I went down
there because if I did not I would have
only just got my MRI a couple days ago
I'd still be waiting for the for the
follow-up consultation insane I go down
there on day one x-rays blood work MRI
and uh the long story short of it is I
did not need to get surgery which is a
huge relief that's awesome I have a
physical in June of 2026 so I'm excited
about it it takes forever dude and
seriously they're like four months from
now every time I call them like why is
it all right great I hope this isn't
cancer what I found I'm in an Uber and
and the Mexican guy is just like
Americans are always coming down here
for medical care and I'm like
unsurprising it's crazy right that's why
they tell you that they just behead you
at the border but they just try to tell
you that they're like the second you get
here cartel yeah you're dead it's
actually the opposite uh what I'm told
is the cartels protect you really yeah
Rich Americans come in Tijuana they
don't want to lose that money no so
they're crazy stories about like locals
who are rob a tourists and then the
cartels find out who did it and let's
just say it doesn't go well for those
people oh that's awesome they love look
American tourists need to be safe and
feel safe if word gets out that you're
not safe in these cities they lose all
that money they're not fans of that so
go back to sandals that's what you're
saying go I Tijuana it was amazing man
it was it was really I haven't been
there in 20 years honestly and it was
really fun the last time I went I gotta
be honest some some of the best would
have ever tasted in my life oh too crazy
but uh who are you what do you do I
think everybody knows you I'm a comic I
have a new shoot new show called normal
world uh Ian's been on it uh and uh yeah
check it out it's on the blaze uh
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday uh 10 p.m
Eastern and yeah that's about it and my
schedule davelando.com awesome well
thanks for hanging out we've also got
Hannah Claire bromelo hi I'm still here
I'm Hannah Claire brimlaw I'm a writer
for timcast.com I'm so happy to be here
with all of you and I'm here with Ian
thank you Hannah Claire yes Dave you
mentioned uh normal world we did the
first episode I was on with you guys yes
drug Topia you started drugtopia one of
the finest shorts ever made here's to
many more my friend that was that was
gorgeous to work on dude you were great
and you were the seriously you were
Robert Downey Jr in that that's
fantastic this last week I've been on a
physical transformation working out I
cut all this weight to do uh the first
scene of this music video we're working
on I've gained like five or six pounds
now and it has been emotional I don't
know about you guys if you've ever done
workout and like the way that uh and I'm
already I think because I'm an actor
or have been that I I'm emotional I kind
of work off how I feel about things and
it's really damaging to my friendships
and my relationships if I don't have it
under control so this has been like a
new learning experience for me man watch
out I'm like a rampaging bull right now
I'm turning into a meathead I'm gonna
get some therapy and then I think maybe
that'll help me balance myself out a
little bit and get jacked and healthy I
noticed around when I got here like the
first time I saw Ian I'm like you can
tell that it would work out and food and
everything is biceps today and after the
first rep of like 10 even I was like gum
I hope my bosses my muscles were like
tight and large it was crazy
but you seem like very hot like
energetic happy it's really interesting
yeah that kind of energy that's for sure
Ian's testosterone's gonna go through
the roof and he's gonna get super
conservative oh yeah that's true it does
come with it it does when you work out
you become right I want to protect
it's true I do have that that that
intuition is kicking on in me this
desire to protect it's really wild we
got Kellen what's up everybody yeah
Ian's uh if you walk by him now in the
hallways he just shoulders you real hard
so we are seeing a change
um but yeah I'm calling I'm filling in
for search Ahoy Dave good to see you my
friend uh uh I get back from you know
this this week-long Retreat and Sheamus
is just gone interesting suspicious and
I know that there were spoons no and
they're gone too true story I wish two
guitars missing Thursday night after a
thousand dollars all of my potatoes
Tuesdays
good question well I went down to eat my
600 calories after the show on Tuesday
and there were no forks and then I was
like Sheamus walked by and I was like oh
God is he kind of a fork guy though I
don't know I just don't trust him I'll
just say I'll just show your hand meal
ma'am I will say uh two very quick
things before we jump into the news we
already got a bunch of super chats one
person said please don't leave again all
Sheamus does is talk about the Bible and
then someone someone else said Sheamus
did great I love that he talked about
the Bible
look religion is apparently the spice of
life occasionally you need to have a
good old Catholic
uh special thank you to Sheamus Sheamus
Coughlin of Freedom Tunes he hosted the
show for the week while I was at the
doctor I was basically sitting in a
recliner with a bunch of tubes and
fluids and stuff and vitamin drips and
blood work and MRIs I saw a lot of
dolphins because the clinic is on the
beach in Tijuana and I saw the Border
too and I actually walked up to the
border and I had this like profound
moment of realization looking at this
massive hole ripped into the the Tijuana
border and I'm just like you could just
walk right through it no joke and then
there's like a border patrol guy on the
other side and then I just had this
realization about the decline of culture
and
everything starts coming together as to
why it's all falling apart and we'll
talk about it on the show let's jump
into the first story
in that regard here we go let's get to
the news we got this from timcast.com
human remains of missing paddle board
are found in pond at Obama's Martha's
Vineyard estate
the man has been described as a black 43
year old but identity has not been made
public now at the time of uh this uh
writing we did not know now we know that
it was Obama's chef
Obama's Chef was paddle boarding this is
uh Dom lukray says dead body found at
Obama's Martha's Martha's Vineyard
estate in search for a black 43 year old
male paddle boarder who drowned in the
pond attached to the estate 9-1-1 call
was made from ex-president's 12 million
dollar property night last night sorry
and uh shortly before 10 a.m the body of
the missing paddle boarder was recovered
from Edgar Town Great Pond by
Massachusetts State Police divers MSP
underwater Recovery Unit made the
recovery after the victim's body was
located so okay it was his Chef
what's going on I think well Michelle
did say he was like family it's just too
bad he knew too much
so this is the thing right what's the
most likely scenario Occam's razor
Obama's Chef went for a paddleboard ride
most likely drowned it's not a cleansing
if it was a Clinton Chef you'd already
find The Bullet Hole did you see that
interview
drowning they would say sorry they would
say uh uh he drowned they would say he
has fixated underwater yeah because the
water entered the bullet hole in his
lungs exactly if you haven't seen the
Patrick Anthony when he talks about the
Clinton Body Count Anthony Weiner goes
off the rails for like 20 minutes it's
hilarious oh Anthony Comey and I did it
once and it's like how many people
commit suicide running through the woods
yelling help and get shot in the back
it's the normal thing that happens I
don't know why you would question it but
to be fair you know so I've gone through
the Clinton Body Count thing and some of
these things are big stretches some of
them are really weird yeah some of them
are a big set I do agree there's there
was that there was that journalist in
the 90s I think it was the 90s he was
like working on the CIA and then they
said he killed himself by shooting
himself twice in the head whatever and
then people will try to explain it away
like well sometimes you know these
horrible things happen people fail and
they try again and it's like okay sure
whatever but a lot of them are like an
accountant an insurance firm the
clintons once used and I'm like oh come
on you're a plane crash like unrelated
they do yeah they do play a lot of uh
Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon in order to
get there in the connection a lot of
them are just like you do I think they
met once at a cocktail party but then
there are some that make no sense at all
for sure and then the question is is
this because the clintons are doing
really evil things yeah or is it is it
they are oh sorry but not in this but
but I'm saying this question in this
specific context yes like in terms of
you know the Clinton Global foundation
and the donations but the the question
is like are they just very powerful
people who are very well connected with
other very very powerful people in a
tight Circle so you hear stories about
security military prominent intelligence
those things happen all the time my my
point is is it unique to the clintons or
if you actually looked would you find
something similar with the Obamas
probably and that is not to say that the
Obama's did anything wrong or the
clintons harmed anyone I'm saying when
you're in these powerful positions of
wealth and Prestige and international
relations I mean come on you know
outside the United States and yeah like
if we're not in this like lovable
rainbow and Butterfly democracy that we
happen to live in right now uh Power
struggles and and people's lives like I
don't think life expectancy is very high
in the center of power in like communist
dictatorships or anything people
offering their friends their their
co-workers no I am gonna pull up this
one YouTube clip and just say because is
it from their ring cam it no it's from
it's not from their kitchen cam it's
from a Marvel movie are you sure yeah we
should have said ring cam
I read this story this is the first
thing I thought of immediately was like
what's that movie where the guy uh is
like in his house and the cleaning lady
leaves and then she comes back in
because she forgot something and then
guy goes Winter Soldier and uh we have
it right here I'm not gonna play the
club I just want to show you this this
is the scene so uh what's his name
Alexander Pierce he's talking with the
Winter Soldier who's like this former
Soviet you know assassin yeah the other
Obama Chef that's right the cleaning
lady leaves and then she like forgets
her phone and she walks back in and then
pierces in there sitting there and he
goes oh Renata I wish you would have
knocked and then he just shoots her yeah
and so it's like that's the first thing
I thought of like why would the chef be
paddle boarding the Obama's house it's
like I I understand you're a chef but
like we we have people who come and
clean the office they don't hang out in
our backyard and go skating and like if
you found them in our you know deer
blind or whatever it'd be weird it's
like a level of comfort you're not
expecting I will say there are some
private chefs especially with these like
more remote private States you know
that'll come spend the week there and
they they have a place that they stay
and maybe he just had like the Africa
yeah but it is weird but we have seen
the Rapids of a pond yeah there's
another person allegedly with him is
that confirmed or denied also were the
Obamas there at the time that's kind of
what I want to know I wonder how big the
pond is also it's hot there's a heat
wave could have been drinking or like if
you just fell off and hit your head and
like that does happen you know what I
mean like someone called 9-1-1
apparently they called it in so someone
knew he was under the water who was it
so is this I mean maybe he was drowning
and they're like help help that's very
possible yeah I feel like there'd be
more that we would know
I I just hope everyone's okay yeah
everywhere I hope everyone's okay it
does seem they're not like we're not
getting all the details right yeah it
feels like something's being hidden and
I think it's always because it's an
ex-president and I I think it's weird
that we haven't gotten any like because
we haven't gotten a the Obamas we're not
there at the time that makes me assume
they were on the estate which like might
explain why their personal chef was
there but also I don't know they're I
just I feel like there's something off
the post-millennial has this they say in
the past Campbell's his name uh wrote
the words still can't swim in a hashtag
on Instagram
so then why was he paddle boarding on
eight feet of water huh is that is that
that's what it was I mean they're not
very big as a foot and a half off what
is a pond they're muddy at the bottom so
if you hit the bottom his feet might
have got tangled that's true it's like
quicksand well like I'm saying Mario if
he like lost balance and there's one
rock there and he hits his head and then
it's that he's unconscious and then he
drunk like that sounds awful but the
reality is occasionally these things
happen no they do no foul play so what
what defines what a pond is it says uh
the technical distinction between the
pond and the lake has not been
universally standardized blah blah blah
some region the US to find Pond as a
body of water with a surface area of
less than 10 acres you know what I can
just pull up satellite images of
Martha's Vineyard yeah like if I was
there with the dude and he fell off his
paddle board I would immediately go in
the water after the guy yeah
blazingly hammered or something like
that more like you go in and even if
you're conscious when you get them out
you still have to call 9-1-1 I feel like
in my drinking days I would have gone in
for sure like that wouldn't have
prevented it at all it may not have
helped that would have been more heroic
I would have been like I got this guys
I'm a swimmer one arm yeah and then
someone would have came in and got us
both so I only have a general idea of
where the Obama's uh house is it's
Martha's Vineyard but yeah but there is
an area that's called a pond I'm not
gonna I don't want to pull it up because
I don't wanna everybody knows where his
house is you can Google it but I'm you
know but there is a pond it's pretty big
it's pretty big you know I don't know
how deep it is but it looks like
decently large enough to go paddle board
on and you know so I don't know I
suppose everybody there's gonna be a lot
of people who would prefer it to be some
kind of uh deeper conspiracy but the sad
reality is it's probably not some dude
who couldn't swim probably just fell off
his paddle board I just probably had a
couple
uh yeah I'm saying he was found at a
depth eight feet and about a hundred
feet from the edge of the shore of the
area yeah that's not good so that seems
he probably didn't get out very far and
realize paddleboard sucks
I was like I'm gonna go back
slipped tafari Campbell he was a sous
chef at the White House during the Obama
Administration and stayed on with the
family when they moved to a private life
so I guess a question like did he live
with them probably if he stayed with him
for that long yeah he's probably lived
at the house and I think that's not
crazy depending on like how big and how
wealth you are like housekeepers
sometimes live and like most people's
houses yeah mine does eight feet oh yeah
that's crazy could you imagine like
being I have one of their bodies just
two feet of water above you and you're
like there is air and you can't get to
it no yeah especially like how tall is
this guy right like if he's over six
feet that's just two feet like yeah for
me I'd be like it's pretty far but for
him that's a distance you know what I
don't understand I don't understand not
being able to swim
well I understand some people can't I'm
just saying you grew up with a pool
or access to one that's how he got his
name sometimes I mean
you know how to swim but uh we didn't we
didn't swim
ever I mean is how to just go like this
though to get up to the surface like I
feel like dogs do that I gotta learn to
cup your fingers that's the biggest part
yeah you know so what I was told when I
was little sideways when I was younger
because I asked like how do people not
know how to swim it's because they Panic
yeah they have to start hitting the
water instead of actually yeah it's
hilarious there was that um actress is
it Nair Rivera she was in Glee and she
drowned one or two years ago at this
point and part of the story was like
it's not that drownings happened so
often there but she was getting her son
out of the water and they think just in
that circumstance it's not that she
couldn't swim but like the Panic of
trying to get her child out and whatever
was happening oh that's right is it like
the ocean or something I think it was in
California on a lake but it could be
slightly nose and Kelly
um I think that's one of the weird
things about drowning people feel like
hopefully some part of your brain kicks
in and says get to the surface but if
you're really Panic you can become kind
of irrational well it's not so so my
understanding is drowning recently in a
pool though and he grew up with a pool I
mean it's an involuntary reaction when
you begin drowning you like that's what
happens is the water goes in your mouth
you try to breathe and then people's
hands go straight out and they just
Panic like not I shouldn't say Panic so
wrong that's not what I'm trying to say
it's like an inventory reaction and
people don't realize they're drowning
because they're not freaking out and
splashing like crazy they're just
sitting there at the water level I think
what it is is God created a water world
and a land world and we're invading it
yeah we kept the salt water inside of us
yeah like we should we shouldn't be in
there messing around with their habitat
you don't see whales walking around like
we take them and bring them here could
you imagine if like dolphins built land
ships we're just like driving yeah just
like looking at us you're anti-watering
watching you through a hole in the fence
I think about that a lot we're like
amoeba that have created this like
sealant around our salt water we just
carry it around with this is freaking
wow right it is yeah so I think we
should just stay out of there it's our
fault what have we done are we
amphibious yeah we've this we've brought
it upon ourselves
you don't think it's Obama you think
this this man who drowned Knew Too Much
about the water he saw something there
they saw him and they were like what are
you doing the murder people in the pond
were like get it get it they were like
look I've made it clear yeah you don't
know what's living in there the Naga we
don't know what he took from the White
House like you could take one thing and
he took like a monster that lives in
ponds yeah
let's jump on to the next really go too
far in this man's death I'm sorry let's
jump on to the next very big story we
have this from timcast.com Twitter
rebrands as X there it is ladies and
gentlemen Elon Musk says not sure what
subtle Clues gave it away but I like the
letter X and that's the new logo I
really like how he tweeted hey we're
gonna you know choose a logo if someone
tweets it or something but then just put
up the logo he already had planned
anyway love it he uh and his newly you
get paid for engagement now so he needs
to keep that coming again this is his
plan to make money he's like I'm gonna
get myself paid he says and soon we
shall bid a dude to the Twitter brand
and gradually all the birds like this
but X so uh here we go this is always
been the plan he's been tweeting about
this for a long time it's official I
like that we've already got uh gang sign
is thrown up yeah Twitter Rex then it
might actually be a gang sign so you
should be careful because you know it's
true yeah no this one is this is blood
but you don't really see him anymore
because the cartels took over L.A but
what do we call tweeting now and he said
it was called an X the more you know I
feel like this one I think I think it's
is it exceeding exceeding I mean I like
love big ziti
I think this is like a Gretchen Wieners
moment we have to be like stop trying to
make acting happen she's not gonna
happen Elon Musk it's maybe not the only
social media site where there's actually
a verb for the word when you send a
message I just say like I'm sending a
mess I posted on mines I posted on
YouTube my post went live on Facebook
but on Twitter it was I my tweet went
live so maybe it's just going to be
called posts you're just posting on next
yeah but that makes it less unique like
I don't understand where to get rid of
that brown that branding uh my favorite
truth no I don't like that one it's hard
that's why it was seven they didn't go
with trumpet or Trump trumpet and you'd
be like trumpeting something I thought
that was pretty cool but uh Chris
degaldo radio host tweeted out this
picture of I don't know what it's from
but like some guy on a crane in a basket
like taking down the to the bird logo
off the side of a building being like by
birds that's why he's making fun of it
like with titter to the WF because he
doesn't care about the brand he's but uh
I want to say this I fear Elon musk's
everything app I fear xai his AI program
Linda yaccarino says the everything app
will be powered by Ai and I feel that
this may actually be somewhat
apocalyptic yes and so I was mentioning
earlier that I was in Tijuana went to
the border and it says big fence there's
Mexican National Guard on one side and
then there's a used Border Patrol on the
other side and there's just this huge
hole that
the average person can easily just walk
right through and the only reason you
don't is because there's guards on the
other side
but I talked with some guy you know he
told me this crazy story our Uber driver
he was like I tried to climb the fence
to break into America and I fell 40 feet
because the car the human traffickers
took the ladder away from me and I'm
just like but I was talking about this
conversation before you go under it was
really crazy I was actually leaving but
um I Heard a story from some guy who
said back in the day a long time ago
yeah there's no border it was like if
you were a Mexican citizen you just
crossed and you'd work and then
Americans would cross and they'd work
yeah you'd walk back and forth yeah it
was no there was nothing there and now
there's this heavy border that's heavily
guarded and I think the issue is with
all of this and and this does relate to
the Twitter rebranding as X the uh
cultural collapse in its entirety
globally
everywhere in the world because of the
internet Community is ceasing to exist
we were talking at dinner about how
there's no Home Eck anymore at schools
they used to teach women and you know to
some degrees I guess men learn this
stuff but mostly women would learn how
to cook dinner and prepare the home and
and iron clothes and help that was
extremely important in my opinion yeah
you had to take it once at least at our
school yeah same we talked about last
week with Libby Evans too on Tuesday
Yeah Tuesday I mean it was such a staple
that this was true at tons of colleges
they had schools of home economics they
would teach things like budgeting they
would teach things like how to cost
compare it was so big that we had a
federal department of home economics
that supported women during war times
and seeing how they could support
basically women helping to sustain the
nuclear family and we don't have that
anymore we have a thousand things for
diversity Equity inclusion but we don't
have things that are specifically
targeted to help people help themselves
in the context of staying at home so to
wrap it all together yeah back to the
Border
the reason I'm freaked out by this is
I'm like we needed this fence because no
one cares about their Community anymore
because now it used to be that someone
would say like hey you're not part of
our community we're we're concerned
about what you're doing here and they
would not get access to public goods
also there was no income tax so people
didn't really care all that much it just
meant you weren't going to fight for us
you weren't gonna be protected by us
Community starts breaking apart so we
have to build walls we have to create
laws why do we need a law that says you
you can't do a certain thing you know
example abortion Ron Paul says it
shouldn't be illegal to be Unthinkable
how did it become thinkable to the point
where we need decree by leadership and
tell people what they can or can't do
instead of our people of the United
States just agreeing like hey we
shouldn't be doing this thing it's
simple culture is fragmenting and
breaking down which brings it all back
to Twitter
it used to be that uh you live next to
your neighbors you went to church you
talked to your neighbors you all agreed
on things you learned from each other
and you shared particular views based on
where you live then the internet came
around big cities started fragmenting
and now there's a dude who lives in New
York on top of another dude and they've
never even met even though they live
next literally next to each other for 10
years people don't talk to their
neighbors at all anymore exactly I
actually talked to mine and it's nice
but there's someone on my blog I haven't
talked to because they're just
completely anti-social but it's because
of the internet of course it is so I
knew everybody on my blog before the
internet everybody nothing about this
AOC is not representative of the average
Democrat or average American she is
fringe leftist she's becoming more chill
establishment she gets elected because
she goes online and typically if you
were like a fringe leftist weirdo you'd
go outside and wave your weird leftist
flag and everyone would be like Sean
shun and you'd be like okay this is not
working now those people go online and
every person in every different part of
the country forms a community of ten
thousand and they share resources and
they organize and they they gain power
in this way I mean same can be said for
even this show we gain power from
everyone from all different all over the
world all over the country coming
together and watching and supporting us
this allows Fringe ideas to become
prominent now think about what it's
going to be like with AI controlling
what you see and hear it's already in
that we're already there
but now it's going to be no matter what
your crackpot insane view is the AI will
Pander to you and affirm your your your
Fringe belief system it's also like the
inner beyond the internet because that's
a really good point the internet is the
beginning of the fracturing of the local
community it's the cell phone you've
brought this up a few times it really
clicked with me a couple weeks ago this
thing it used to be that you'd be on the
internet when you sat down at your
computer you were there for an hour or
whatever then you got up and walked away
and you were not online ever for the
rest of the day everybody around you is
who you are with now these stupid things
when some you're trying to talk to
someone and they're on their
phone uh it's it's the most like
disheartening experience if you have a
friend and like they're just not
available because I call it dinner with
my family yeah it's
so that's crazy well it is I mean have
you ever looked at your phone sometimes
and you re you've had a busy day doing
stuff that you've had to do and you look
and you go nine hours
and you just realize that's what you've
been doing for more than a work day is
staring at a screen so what's going to
happen is horrific you're talking about
how it could even the AI is going to
start moving people like if you have a
brain implant or or a phone or like some
sort of sensor in your augment augmented
glasses and someone tells you something
and the machine's like they're lying
they're lying they're lying you're gonna
that's the AI making you think something
about that person like they're gonna
have behavioral monitoring devices and
stuff that people can tap into this is
this person a psychopathic
behavioral experimentation right we see
this with a Twitter algorithm or not
just Twitter but any of the social media
algorithms you know you'll get people
who say oh yeah we changed one small
thing and we saw this reaction so let me
change this way like they are already
collecting all data I can only imagine
what AI is going to decide it wants to
do I don't trust AI I don't like it at
all I recognize that there are some
reasons why we're curious about it but I
think ultimately just like Tim like the
the idea that we'd have this super app
like where's name one other place that
has that China I mean that's the idea
right is China has the one app that
controls everything that's what
everybody sees all day is the only one
thing that monitors everyone I mean
that's the idea is the government
watches everybody on one specific app is
that what this is
how could it not be the fact that it
collects all that data like even though
we're not giving it to the government
necessarily the fact that everything
you're doing of course I mean exactly
because we've known this since Snowden
and we all yeah people hated them even
even it's like all they did was tell us
like what we needed to know and it's
like even even if Elon disagrees with it
even if Elon shuts down these backdoors
it doesn't mean they're not going to
look at it they still can buy because
they control the grid I don't get it
because Elon I think of as like a
brilliant genius like one of the most
genius strategists on Earth right now
why he would centralize data it doesn't
make any sense like you could
decentralize the system work on a mesh
Network maybe that's your goal overall
but why do you got to centralize
everything first it's such a
vulnerability point I'll tell you what I
think
I don't know this is absolute or true
but it's what's happening you think
about I think we talked about this in
one of the cultural episodes you think
about single-celled organisms what do
they do what are they doing Milling
about eating particles or whatever and
molecules and making more of themselves
I haven't the foggiest I haven't
foggiest it seems irrelevant to us but
eventually a bunch of these little dudes
got together and created this massive
network of complicated specialized cells
to make us right
in our bodies when a group of cells goes
Rogue what do we call it
cancer yes and we destroy it yes because
it's deviating from what we want these
free radicals I love how they're called
free radicals that can like result in
cancer because I'm like that sounds like
the free radicals we have in society
that are running around doing crazy a
lot of fun young radicals are banned
yeah well it's either so here's what I
think is happening not a good band why
would Elon want this
so everybody you will live in you'll owe
nothing you will live in your pod you
will eat the bugs and you will be happy
you this is the the Communist
techno-communist future
the next stage in the evolution of life
is multicellular organisms all becoming
hyper-specialized never deviating in any
way you are born to do a job you are
engineered to do a job probably
genetically the AI controls what you
think so you never deviate you never
want to deviate you're scared to
deviating if you do then you get removed
yeah and then what happens is the AI
will effectively be the brain telling
all of the individual multicellular
humans what the massive multicellular
multi-organism is supposed to be doing
the AI will effectively be the conscious
entity of all humanity and will be
nothing but a skin cell to be flicked
off and destroyed
I believe I shave my dick for this
um with this though like if you look at
it I see what you're saying but okay
let's hear Elon Musk right you have
electric cars AI all these different
things that he's that he's doing which
one of the these things going towards
this does he not benefit from so even
though you look at him like a good guy a
genius these things that he that he does
don't you think that there could be a
chance that this maybe isn't the
greatest guy in the world and it could
be benefiting him completely yeah the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions that's what I mean he can
he's always worried me in that sense
like I hate electric cars I'll just say
it but that's just because maybe being
from Detroit I just like the feel of an
actual car and that's just a preference
of mine but I don't get in a Tesla and
be like this is cool I just it's
something I don't enjoy personally I
like it but understand whether it's
Tesla or any other electric car oh I'm
not saying it's just his brand it's just
how I feel about it whatever car it is
there will come a day very soon yeah
where I'm not allowed to drive get in
the car and the doors will lock it says
a warrant has been issued for Mr Landau
right driving to the police station your
fingerprints on the steering wheel or
something no the camera right there look
at your face face recognition says hello
Dave a warrant has been issued by
Precinct 99 and you'll be like okay I'm
like delivering you to jail that's why I
want like a older gas guzzler that has
none of those features I never love
those cars there are very few of them at
this point yeah they're trying to get
them away and but I think a lot of
people feel that way because lots are
filled with electric cars right now
people aren't buying them and I think
that's out of that fear I think descent
is part of the United States ethos like
if there's corrupt government you
descent create a better government by
the people like the people govern
themselves but the rest of the world's
not really built like that they they're
much about fall in line a lot of them
are like oh I think you're right about
that for sure and it's bleeding into our
culture I can feel it with this whole
like everyone organized on the centered
system it's better like the world
economic Forum they want everything like
monitored and I don't know think about
this here's the real danger in my mind
of this hyper centralized AI dictating
everything yeah using the human body as
as the metaphor the next stage All
Humans specialized being controlled no
free radicals to be eliminated Etc the
ai's in control there are people whose
conscious minds are in control of their
bodies gorging themselves to death and
doing drugs and destroying their bodies
yeah and still when they get cancer we
destroy it
so that what freaks me out in that idea
is not not that's one for one but let's
say we do move in this direction where
AI controls everything we don't even
realize it the AI could be gorging
itself on drugs and sugars and we would
just be Milling about being like
everything so perfect until in the
entirety of humanity collapses we cannot
trust a centralized AI to make sure to
or or to follow or any of this and it's
where everything's been going in the
past couple of decades well and really
even in the past couple I don't know I
shouldn't even say months but really
it's already had so many problems with
AI that it's really like upsetting
people to the point that you have ice
cube you have other people speaking out
about the fears of it oh sorry am I not
lower it you're good sorry
um but you have you have people speaking
out against it you already have so many
problems with it just in I guess it's
not in its infancy but I think compared
to the you know technology it really is
there's already been so many issues with
this don't you think that there's other
places to go they're going to be far
more dangerous than just the tiny stuff
that we've seen yeah I I as you were
talking about how it's we're having
problems with AI I got this article from
fortune.com chat GPT went from correctly
answering a simple math problem 98 of
the time to just two percent of the time
so the way an AI can flip and be have
everything looks good and then one
little piece of data can switch in the
entire system can start outputting
something that's just slightly wrong but
that's just wrong enough to destroy the
entire thing it takes so much effort to
make it right and it's so easy to fail
have you guys seen where video games are
already at with this stuff dude it's
crazy it used to be
Super Mario Brothers Mario goes in the
castle and text appears thank you for
saving me but the prince is in another
castle that was the extent of NPC
communication with you it Advanced two
games now where you can choose to say
something and then a voice actor's
scripted line will speak that's a great
idea let's get the mission underway and
you're like cool now with text to voice
and predictive language models video
games have already started you're
wearing a headset you walk up to the NPC
and you say something like hey idiot
ugly I want to buy some soda and the a
the NPC goes or you calling an idiot if
you want to buy something be polite a
generated predictive response we are we
are years away from people saying I no
longer want to live in reality I'm going
to go into this universe where I can
tune out and you're going to be sitting
in your living room talking to fake
people and we're we're already there
with the robot girlfriends man y'all's
getting crazy out there well and how
many people want to live in the current
reality
is it intense I mean it's not really
that great right now I mean the last
couple years everything has fallen
completely and I'm sure a lot of people
would prefer to live in the south I mean
I'm just saying it's in the headlines
that go behind that right like you're a
millennial they're saying it's gonna be
possible by a house it's gonna be
possible for a family like there's all
of these negative things at some point
it would be easy to be like I'm just
giving up like this place that gives me
Comfort and gives me the life I want is
easier right I can understand the
attraction of that I just think
ultimately that's really devoid of
actual emotional connection and support
I think part of the issue is that we
train people to uh seek out momentary
pleasure and comfort rather than work
through issues that they're having uh
well yeah it's easier to give up yeah
the idea of community and you take out
the idea of a lot of things like that
when you do want that instant
gratification which we've completely
taught our society to have as endless
dopamine hits and instant likes and no
attention span but then you add like the
other day I saw a video is for basically
gen Z's and Millennials where it's just
if you want to buy a 500 thousand dollar
house all you need is a twenty five
thousand dollar down payment and then
you need three thousand dollars a month
at a six point five percent interest
rate I'm like wow that sounds like hell
like pure hell to try to pitch that to
somebody it doesn't look good I mean
you're basically telling people that a
reality of the old of a way that life
once worked is no longer available but
it's a complete turn off I don't know
I'm just saying that's not like a
realistic it's not a realistic interest
rate it's not a realistic down pay it's
none of that's even it's all pretend I
don't just in that I don't agree that's
bad uh the the amount so the issue is
relativity and the issue with VR is that
it will always offer you the greener
grass no matter what it is yeah you're
not going to go back 200 years and say
that we have it worse you know actually
there's there's no lights anywhere it's
dark out you could just die you stub
your toe you get infection you're dead
horrible things are going on and even as
bad as it is now relative to how things
may have been in economic booms or
whatever sure it's still pretty great of
course but there will always be struggle
there will always be problems and people
will always choose a free dopamine hit
over the harsh reality they live in yes
so when the VR starts coming out and
it's already here with predictive
language NPCs within a year or two the
language will be perfectly fluid right
now it's it's rather hey why are you
calling me ugly that was mean
it give it a year or two it's going to
be perfect I mean we went in in one year
with AI images I tweet out this horrible
image of Pelosi one year later you have
photorealistic images being made in my
mid-journey and getting better every day
dude I would picture like you play the
video game with the guy Elder Scrolls 7
or whatever and he's talking to you and
you're like then you're dreaming and
you're thinking about that one NPC like
that guy's really cool man and then
there's an app where you can actually
call that NPC on the phone when you're
not playing the game and bond with them
and talk to them and the next time
you're in the game they could make it so
the generative conversation was involved
or not involved oh dude no I don't like
that at all the only social skills you
have now though is that and and imagine
the people who are going to retreat to
significant others there's going to be
we're a year out from this at at most
people sitting in their living room
wearing a headset playing a video game
and talking to a computer programming
saying I love you so much and the
computer program just goes I love you
too I really wish I could be there with
you then how long until we download
those AIS into machines and it's here's
here's the thing so how long is it until
it's just porn and nobody leaves their
house ever that's exactly but but more
than for real like not even kidding but
emotional and physical porn at the same
that's what I mean the hero yeah you get
to have sex with the woman it's gonna be
crazy yeah realistic I mean and then it
goes farther than that because obviously
we've taken something that and I guess
too what I mean by Nostalgia isn't even
200 years if you looked When We Were
Young and the amount of the amount of
nostalgia that just we have in our
Generations is insane because of how
fast technology moved you know so what
we see is crazy like the amount of
Technology we have seen is it's not like
it's ever been this way for a group in
history we remember pre-inner at and the
way that things were and the way that
things are now so the way that this all
affects us the technology is different I
think it's going to be different than
the people that are born today because
they're growing up with this with all of
this technology it's not going to be
anything new or that crazy to them but
what going from playing like you said
getting a Nintendo when I was a kid to
seeing all of this it makes very little
sense to me let's uh let's jump into
this next story and talk about how we
might get there we got this one from
NDTV I see this story popping popping up
all over the place man tests positive
for MERS Coronavirus in Abu Dhabi says
World Health World Health Organization a
28 year old man it says a positive for a
potentially fatal Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome coronavirus now
here's the thing MERS has been around
for a while right they say what is it um
it's been recorded in 27 countries since
2012 over the time 2605 cases and 936
Associated deaths have been reported
here's what I want to say about this a
lot of people are suggesting this could
be the Catalyst for another lockdown as
elections are looming I don't think so
MERS has been around before it doesn't
spread like kovid did kovid was novel
but they're calling it MERS Dash COV
that's the freaky thing that's what I'm
seeing a bunch of these stories do
because now they're associating MERS
with kovid yeah that could be a
political Catalyst for giving the
government power to do whatever they
want I think I saw there was a 25 death
it kills like 30 percent of the people
in 36 36 so that's nothing like covert
that's something where like you get it
either survive it or you die
uh and it's not really that I don't know
if how transmissible it is one in three
sorry Dave were you about to say
something no no it just sounds like they
added three letters to MERS exactly
because now they're associating the
pandemic the lockdown the sickness with
something that they can say is a 36
mortality rate despite the fact it does
not spread nearly as as horrifically but
could be enough for politicians to say
hey MERS see MERS kovid is here
we need lockdowns we need mail-in voting
the mortality rate is 36 percent oh boy
here we go again yeah I do feel like
they feel like covet has uh worn out you
know they've been saying for a while
they had all the the variants and at a
certain point they were like seems like
people aren't going to stay at home no
matter what and now we have the malaria
outbreaks which malaria can be really
serious but it is interesting that
there's almost at times if I'm if I'm
cynical feels like they're just trying
to test out what will scare you enough
to go home oh I think they are though I
mean and with this it's I I don't think
you can have another covet lockdown
because everybody's just gonna go yeah
no I'm not going to do that at all I I I
don't know if I agree with that do you
think they will some people maybe but I
I don't think the majority we're still
calling for it you still have prominent
liberal person
saying yeah yeah
we put it out just recently I got locked
down again yeah he said something like
that yeah he was he's the worst
Professor Peter's MD PhD he's terrible
yeah he's didn't he write a book called
vaccines and give my daughters autism I
did from junk food he was like Glee
telling Joe Rogan that he feeds his
autistic daughter junk food yeah
like in blame it's insane that yeah that
guy is a he's just worthless
but was wasn't he just saying recently
something about like you know I'm
looking at his Twitter I can't find it
oh it was the post Barbie yeah in this
post Barbie world let's not forget I'm
I'm nervous about coming as long as
everyone's go to the movies so he was
like oh but no one's masking anymore no
one's doing tests anymore I think that
was the Tweet right yeah it was
something like that the movies are so
popular we have to worry about another
rise in covid basically which is also
like a typical like don't go have fun
I'm holier than you for have noticing
notice this I'm protecting you all with
my my great ideas we have anonymous sex
apps and we're worried about people
going to the movies it's absurd go to
the movies bring a wipe if you want with
you but haven't we already proven that
putting on a mask with Dirty Fingers
isn't going to help you all that much
oh my gosh I don't know especially like
are we allowed to say that I don't know
100 yeah if you're rebreathing like
fecal matter in your mask
you put it in your bag or your coat
pocket like bad things here's here's a
tweet dirty underwear it's the same
sorry no no I just want to pull the
Tweet uh Peter said not to be a Debbie
Downer but anyone worried about a post
Barbie box office coveted bump or post
Opie we'll net we'll probably never know
since no one seems to be keeping track
of such things anymore keep up with your
boosters and find a pink n95 or KN 95 if
you can
and he's just talking about the box
office for these two movies now I don't
know if that really matters but I I do
want to stress this is this is my point
these people are still calling for these
things to happen again
yo there were a lot of places where
people did not follow the protocols yeah
I didn't but there were a lot of places
that did to an extreme degree absolutely
and there was enforcement of these
things to ridiculous degrees so I don't
think it's an issue of whether people
want or don't want something because
they let it happen in the first place
and local cops and Sheriff's Department
went and arrested Cafe owners and salon
owners the cops will do as they're told
a lot of those things are hard once they
get started they're easier to stop from
happening once it gets rolling then
you're like especially as a cop you're
like well got there to put it into place
now I've got to kind of do my job and
enforce the dumb rule that got put into
place but if you don't let them put the
rule into place in the first place but
this also had though a lot of cops
though the new business owners that were
like you know what you don't have to
build your restaurant outside it's fine
you have a speakeasy now I mean there
were a lot of places in this country who
didn't deal with it you know I mean you
can't I guess legally you can't say that
or have a statistic on it speakers
existed in in prohibition of course and
there were cops who would look the other
way and things like that but
I'm not saying it was the majority
unfortunately you are right I think what
happens is the fragmentation of
community and the family and partly due
to the internet what do they do in New
Jersey with atelis gym they brought the
local cops didn't do what the city
wanted so they got cops from a different
Suburban town to come in and enforce the
law
here's the crazy thing about all that
why would any Community accept external
police
coming into their Community to enforce
rules their Community does not agree
with is the crazy thing but is the proof
to what I'm talking about yep irrational
fear they had to bring in state troopers
into New York because a lot of NYPD guys
didn't want to enforce these rules like
shut down bars and stuff so they bring
in a different uh agency now I can
understand the hierarchy of law
enforcement State Police have different
jurisdiction they have more jurisdiction
but the idea that there are two cities
let's call it city city town and town
city CityVille in the village of cities
Town whatever and uh
one cities like we want to force
everyone in their homes but they're
refusing and the cops won't enforce it
let's bring in cops from a different
town why would anyone in the community
be like we certainly respect this uh
this Police Department with no
jurisdiction in our town but they did
that's the point yes they did I guess my
point is how do we continue making a
living in this country how do we not
keep everybody from going completely
impoverished how do we keep any brick
and mortar business going any restaurant
running anything really working that's
not just a giant Corporation where you
work in a warehouse wearing a mask all
day sweating I mean really what what's
the end game I mean it does go at a lot
of this x stuff we were talking about
and going into that sort of Bleak future
but why why wouldn't we fight against
that I think that question is a good
question for Peter Hotes and people like
Peter Hotes that made tons of money and
became super well known during the
pandemic because of the pandemic if that
guy has everything to gain from seeing
another pandemic the way he made out
during covet without it he becomes
irrelevant yeah yep think about how many
people
are sitting there thinking all these
doctors they're like oh man I'd love I
mean fauci's on a TV anymore right well
no the once people found him to be a
slight bit Shady they had to finally you
know kind of push him to the side they
put MSNBC he didn't push him aside for
being shady well no they don't care they
they held big umbrellas with his face on
it it's twirled around on was it Jimmy
Kimmel or something or Colbert or
whatever oh yeah the dancing needles he
didn't get booted from TV because he was
shady because covet's not relevant
anymore so they don't need him people
like that they're salivated the idea of
locking down again because it keeps them
in the news and it gives them power of
course they love power yeah that's what
a large part of it is is power and
that's the problem is if if you're
supposed to be somebody who's out there
protecting the public and all you do is
hurt people why would anybody believe
you anymore I don't understand the logic
now I do agree people are dumb I mean
not even dumb they're they're scared and
they are definitely going to believe
things and they're going to be gullible
and they're going to do anything to
protect their families but how much more
evidence do you need that didn't work
I with I have a theory with fauci I
think that he really believed he was
helping people and he was being used by
the pharmaceutical industry to sell
Pharma drugs for profit they're like
let's just find a guy that's obsessed
with public health because I tried to
picture fauci being in a bathroom be
like we're gonna make so much money on
this but I just don't see it and that's
why people liked him the amount of
people that did because he truly
believed what he was saying like they're
gonna help you you're gonna get the
thing it's gonna be great you're going
to be fine wear two masks and everyone's
like
he believes it so I believe him isn't he
the highest paid government employee
though he was he was he makes he was
making tons of money he has the biggest
pension or maybe not anymore but to me
it's hard to believe that this guy isn't
aware of money especially when he signed
up to do a documentary with Disney I
mean like yeah I made AIDS worse and not
pro like a girl there is a desire to
have attention be famous there I think
money the desire to be compensated and
paid is part of that yeah and it's
almost irrelevant to Muse about what his
intentions were yeah we'll never know
but he did make a lot of money I would
imagine he comes on the show and he
became very that would be awesome well
and they were pumping out that
documentary while they're like you know
the human trafficking one just keeps
that one shelf let's make sure everybody
finds out about how great fauci is it's
just recently yeah oh I didn't see it
what's it called uh the sound of freedom
I was talking about the fauci doc oh no
there was the one on Disney plus oh yeah
they they shelved sound of freedom and
now it's a sleeper hit yep makes 125
million so far yeah yeah
and now with the the smear from the left
is these Outlets is that no one's
actually seeing the movie
that in reality they're just paying for
tickets but no one actually is seeing it
we need to pay it forward you're so
desperate that's that's like a terrible
argument you can literally buy tickets
from scanning at the end of the movie
and people are buying them so let's say
they're not then people are still buying
those tickets I bought a thousand
dollars worth of them just to give them
away yeah Pay It Forward thing I thought
that was a cool thing I bought a ton of
tickets but it wouldn't matter one way
or the other it's still profiting for
the movie let's talk about this we got
the story from the guardian let's pull
this up sound of Freedom past the 100
million dollar Mark who's really
watching the movie they say the Q Anon
adjacent film co-opted by the right wing
has a Pay It Forward scheme resulting in
sold out shows but empty theaters that
is a lie flat Outlaw their evidence is
that they went to a local theater check
out the weasel language they use here
according to Fandango all but 28 seats
had been sold for the 3pm screening of
sound of Freedom as the lights dimmed
however the guardian counted 45 vacant
seats dotted around the half empty
theater full stop
the lights dim twice
when a movie ends the lights go full
brightness
then the lights will dim slightly for
pre like the the movie go whatever it's
called pre-screener where it's like you
know lasers and you hold your phone and
stuff then it dims then the lights shut
off
my question is
are they lying by manipulating so uh
being factual but not truthful in that
when the lights dim half a theater was
empty are you saying that people showed
up early for the movie and then when the
lights dimmed for the previews the
theater was half empty or are you sang
When the Lights actually dimmed for the
start of the film The Theater was empty
check this out he says minutes before
the 6 30 screening Fandango showed that
only two seats were available again
there were more than two vacant spots as
the film began three
wow that was more than two mean well
that's empty more than two definitely
means it's not a cell no one is there it
sounds like what actually happened was
the theater was half full before the
previews even started right the lights
dim and they're like theaters fmt yeah
then before the movie actually starts
there's like six seats that are
available and they're like more than two
some people didn't shop yeah some people
missed their movie well take a look at
this currently sound of freedoms at 124
million years Obama's chef that's right
and uh number three only behind Barbie
and Oppenheimer of course those are the
big movies that just came out
sound of freedom is beating Mission
Impossible
yes sorry Tom Cruise take that beating
Mission Impossible you know the flash is
considered the biggest one of the if it
may be the biggest box office bomb in
history wow did it just come out it's
odd when you take somebody who kidnaps
women and tortures them and then you're
like you can still be the Flash
oh yeah what's that guys yeah they made
back like 260 of their 400 million so
they were like we can't cancel this film
I'll look I'll take 50 cents in the
dollar but I'm thinking I'm not taking
zero yeah I really like Michael Shannon
too I feel bad that he's got to take a
hit on that one yeah who is he in the
movie uh I guess he's the bad guy I
don't know who he plays but I wonder how
many of the people involved with the
flash are making money off of it like
when 240 million comes in of your 400
does the production house eat it and
they're like sorry BlackRock ESG we'll
we'll pay it forward yeah we'll donate
to some kids in Rwanda or something I
also feel that with superhero movies
it's like it's fine we'll just make it
all back with every other superhero
movie we make this year yeah don't worry
about it I assume it's not like per
movie there's an ultimate you know yeah
and even that it's like yeah we lost a
couple hundred million but we still made
back a few hundred million so it's not
like the end of the world for these
studios Okay no I I mean I think I think
it's about Netflix right now Netflix had
a bunch of um like house related
flipping show shows that are all Netflix
originals like that they're like you're
looking at these these things you're
like how much is the budget per episode
here but it's because ultimately Netflix
is trying to decide which style of show
people are going to watch which they'll
renew they're able to throw up a ton of
losses if they can ultimately decide
it's worth it as a business investment
because they are making money off of
other things yeah did you know there was
a movie called Ruby Gilman teenage
Kraken that came out no I'm just like
looking at the box office this is the
one where there's like a mermaid yeah I
mean it was like a month and a half ago
I guess right that one must be doing
very bad terrifier the blackening of the
boogeyman the blackening I wanted to see
what is it it's like a horror movie but
it's uh it's by the people that did
um get out oh no not get out but yeah I
see I see what you did I don't know I
know movies no no they did um they did a
parody two of another uh it is like
parodies of Black movies
um but this one is yeah they all go to a
camp or go to a house in the woods so it
is like all black people in a in the
woods horror movie the the tagline is we
can't all die first exactly yeah that's
awesome yeah so I do want to see that
one actually the big the big news is
uh we're nearly 20 or 20 days only about
three weeks on sound of Freedom uh it's
on Saturday hit 7.5 million dollars
beating uh I'm sorry on Friday they beat
Mission Impossible by 200k about 140k
they lost Sunday by about 400k but then
uh almost a 700 000 sound of Freedom
beats Mission Impossible on Sunday the
crazy thing is
sound of Freedom has consistently been
hitting Millions every day Saturday July
15th 10 million dollars Friday 7 million
dollars this is amazing so here's what I
want to say about the guardian
they're trying to make it seem like
suspicious sales the theaters are empty
but they're claiming they saw it and I'm
like there were two seats with people
that weren't even in them if you think
you're gonna go to Hollywood Studios and
say
don't support these movies people are
willing to pay to see it and not
actually even go to the theater
the studio is going to be like hold on
people are giving money in exchange for
nothing they're just like literally
giving their money away
can we make more of these why would a
studio say no to that yeah or a movie
house because it's less upkeep on the
house to have to clean after exactly
people have to be like with their
morality tales and the guy the studio is
like oh I work for the devil yeah is
there a way to do this yeah
we're evil yeah yeah uh oh I can't make
these at all it's kind of even our
contract I just I I love how their smear
is this movie was so important that
people are paying for tickets but not
actually going as if that's going to
like discredit it in any way it's the
most cat it's a capitalist dream you
mean I can bake the cake and keep it and
you're gonna pay me money anyway just
yeah that's amazing and you know this
semi-feminist uh Barbie movie is not
able to say the same thing like our
movie's so culturally important please
buy tickets for other people people you
may not even know like where is the
Barbie go buy tickets for other people
camping it doesn't exist because that
movie obviously doesn't tell a story
that people want to hear or feel a moral
imperative to share with other people
that's what's one of the things that's
so unique about sound of Freedom you
just can't replicate that everywhere
well no and it's a it's very important
for people to see I mean I have a son
right after I saw it he was yelling he
was wearing bright yellow for the next
three days because it's haunting I mean
it really is a terrible story and it's
it's very real I I think it's odd that
it's taken this long for people to kind
of open their eyes in this way to human
trafficking because it's everywhere and
it's been everywhere in plain sight for
a very very long time but at least it's
finally out there and people are getting
to be a little bit more aware of it but
it it it's important and it's important
that these tickets are available for
people because a lot of it is just for
people who can't afford to go to the
movies that's why people are buying them
so you can just see it yeah it matters
and that's not Barbie it's like you've
made 800 Barbies now for everybody where
you have like handicapped wheelchair
Barbie you have spina bifida Barbie you
have all these things but then you make
the movie and it's just hot ass Barbie
he's not joking ladies and gentlemen no
I'm sorry why didn't lizzo play about I
was shocked she didn't but like it's
like real though no I I they were like
they would that's why everyone tried
claiming Margot Robbie was unattractive
because the reality was oh I know she's
she's conventional Hollywood attractive
she's like the conventional Hollywood
beautiful actress yes but they have to
say that because then people are gonna
come up oh why wouldn't Barbie it's a
feminist film why didn't they cast lizzo
or a trans woman
yeah that's true that's why I don't even
look at the cover of Sports Illustrated
because I don't know anymore
you know well the reality is their
ideology is it's it's nonsense here's
the funny thing remember the movie Bros
you know that one yeah I know oh Billy
Billy Eichner is a gay comedy one yeah
okay nope it bombed miserably no it's
like one of the worst yeah bombs yeah
and he's he's at this show and he's
walking through the I'll be like
everybody please go see this movie you
have to nobody wanted to pay a dime for
it especially gay men but I mean look
maybe they did want to see it I don't
know I'm just saying he's the ones I
knew were like no but if you're talking
to three percent or like point in one
one percent of the population your
market cap is going to be one percent of
typical box office market cap if you
make a movie that's like called all men
are dumb don't expect men to go see it
if you make a movie about a gay
relationship don't expect straight
people to go see it well they didn't
here's the thing sound of freedom is the
inverse of that people on the right post
liberals people who care about this
issue
they want the movie so badly they're
willing to pay extra for other people to
go see it yeah it's like information
like you're actually going to see to
learn some information it is a doc It's
a drama about a real life story but
you're still learning like about real
life things so it's like it's like a
documentary and sadly you're getting
clips of the real life events yeah
literally yeah and that's that's
horrifying but when you see it you
realize how you know how fast it can
happen yep and how you know little
people can do about it because you have
grown men with guns who pull up to kids
playing soccer or whatever on the street
and what are they gonna do they're just
trying to save whatever kids are just
sitting there and then you have and then
who what are the most egregious places
where human trafficking happens they go
right to Los Angeles it's one of the top
three I I also want to point this out
too
in the guardian storages in a theater
located in New York City's Times Square
on Thursday afternoon there seemed to be
evidence of this you mean to tell me
that a Thursday afternoon they sold half
the theater out I don't buy it no no a
Thursday yeah yeah we we always go who
goes to a 3 P.M Thursday showing the if
you even look at the sign of Freedom box
office it's big days are weekends duh
this is why movies get released with
Thursday previews over weekends so
you're saying two weeks out almost three
weeks out on a Thursday they were able
to put Philip half the theater yeah come
on well it looks like they filled up
almost the entire theater by the time
the movie started no no two seats all
but two at least two seasons more than
two that means three do you think there
were tourists on a Tuesday afternoon in
times maybe but what I find fascinating
is the the fact that they're not
acknowledging that you could go to any
movie and be like one of two people in
the theater and they still consider that
movie a success right this this idea
that they're not feeling they're not
selling out every single show every
single time but they're still making
tons of money is it relevant to them
they're manipulating all of their data
to try to make this look bad it's the
same thing with this like q and onsler
right like they have just decided this
might be the way to scare people away
from going right to say like actually
that many people aren't seeing it you're
you're confused because actually not
every seat is sold and we checked this
one time like it's it's ridiculous well
it's interesting because it's the only
place in Times Square that you're not
spending money on human trafficking at
that hour
man no it's true I'm just saying it's a
creepy place
for a while you do yeah there's really
and then well of course if you eat don't
finish your Red Lobster you can just set
it on a homeless guy's tent because that
seems like a good idea until he wakes up
and he's like why are there rats
everywhere
there's his meme Rolling Stone said
something like the Q Anon film insulting
sound of freedom and then next to it
it's juxtaposed with the in defense of
cuties oh yeah very weird that you would
you would try and dog that sound of
freedom of you it was pretty how can you
give a good review to something like
cuties or something that obviously
exploits children and then you're like
well I didn't care for the acting in
this one you're like you mean the real
footage yeah the real footage of it
happening it's almost like they're okay
with children being harmed something is
something about that I can see this if
the argument they're making if like for
instance of the 130 million 30 million
dollars was like George Soros or some
wealthy investor that bought a bunch of
paid forward a bunch of tickets and no
one saw them and you're like yes 30 of
the numbers were inflated that would be
a story but if it's like people two or
three people didn't show up to a Tuesday
Afternoon movie like wait the jury's out
wait till we have some real Data before
you try and start slandering this thing
because people obviously like it well
let's let's see what you said though
though it's like sorry I didn't mean to
it's like you said a sense of community
all of a sudden there is a slight sense
of community right and people are
freaking the hell out and writing
articles about it let's talk about Snow
White we had this from TMZ they say
Rachel zegler Snow White old woke
interview resurfaces ignites right wing
rage it's really weird to me that honest
and
average is considered right wing because
you go and talk to the average person
and you will find they hold these
opinions so anyway you may have seen the
news that yeah this image as Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs I'm pretty sure
that's not what's called anymore because
now it's like what is it the Seven
Companions or something yeah and one's a
dwarf just the one guy just the one so
you've got you know like a white guy
you've got a couple black people you got
a fat guy another white guy a guy who's
presumably black maybe ethnically
ambiguous one uh little person and then
another guy so uh the story apparently
is the new Snow White movie will not be
about her being rescued by Prince
Charming or anything like that it's
gonna be her trying to actualize her
girl boss dreams or something yeah
we should watch the interview it's just
really that's the worst it's terrifying
two minutes here we go you said you were
bringing a Modern Edge to it on stage
what do you mean by that I just mean
that it's that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely absolutely wrote a snow
white that is not going to be saved by
The Prince
and she's not gonna be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and
you'll hear that her late father told
her that she could be if she was
Fearless Fair Brave and true so patreon
so it's just a really incredible story
for I think young people everywhere it's
not Snow White no white is running for
president so you're a Hispanic campaign
a.m deal is fair Brave and true like
was it yes Snow White was like cleaning
yeah for the house yeah so but that's
what she's saying they're not gonna do
Oh I thought she was still had that same
role but then she wants to be a a boss
no no no this movie is not Snow White
it's like there's no dwarfs dwarves I
don't know but here's the worthless she
never touches him but here's what
bothers me about it yo the the Seven
Dwarves were not little people they were
fictional yes they're called creatures
who mined gemstones
they needed more diversity World of
Warcraft you're done you gotta get rid
of the whole dwarf race this idea it's a
stereotype that little people are mining
I don't know where it comes from but
it's gone they look like gnomes too like
The Gnome the World of Warcraft yeah
they weren't like yeah they weren't like
their fictional mystical characters I
mean this is ridiculous like they were
like they represented emotions
now now hold on there a minute do you
think they're gonna to give these names
to these people Dopey who's gonna be
Dopey who's the one that's on heroin
yeah sleepy is also on heroin yeah yes
that doesn't have heroin yet Doc is just
he's the pill Mill this this reminds me
yeah this reminds me more of a hook the
movie with with Robin Williams and
Dustin Hoffman yes with a Peter Pan
movie and these look like the lost boys
like they're just kind of regurgitating
the Lost Boys yeah one is Rufio except
she's just drugging her all the time I'm
sorry dude this movie's gonna bounce
it's gonna bomb because here's what's
happening
regular people like I went outside I was
I'll wait touching grass actually I was
touching sand because I was in Tijuana
but I'm I'm hanging out and talking to
regular people about all the stuff and
they're like don't know don't care this
is weird they just want regular stuff
like we're used to you can't have this
rapid
cultural shift in the span of six seven
years people are just weirded out by now
terminally online people on the woke
left will say things that make no sense
just agree with each other like uh you
know everyone brings up to me non-stop
the clip with um Lance from the Surfs
when he said a woman should be able to
get an abortion whatever she wants it's
her body and then asked him about
Matthews well she can't do that
intentionally kills the baby everybody
and then Dave Chappelle goes gotcha
so everybody someone made that
edit and uh that that is a contradiction
in the mind of an individual who doesn't
have convictions or logic he has tribal
acceptance he will say what he is
supposed to say and of course this is
why many leftists Don't Come on talk
shows because there's no logic to their
ideas they're saying things that they're
supposed to say
regular people don't live in that world
so when you bring woke snow white girl
boss and the Seven Companions they're
gonna be like oh
are they gonna do a snow white with the
prince I wanna see that
real love they think about it all the
time and relationships it's way they're
hardwired to pretend otherwise is stupid
it's disingenuous also ridiculous I saw
this interesting thing on Twitter and it
said the reason women get offended by
mansplaining is because men and women
communicate with each other differently
men talk to each other about things they
know women talk to each other about
their feelings on average so when a man
starts talking to a woman he starts
talking about knowledge-based things and
the woman doesn't like it women talk
about feelings that's what they prefer
more and you better listen so but but
ultimately what it comes down to is
how many people really she's like it's
not 1937 anymore she's gonna be the
leader she can be okay well here's an
honest question
how many women genuinely want to be
world leaders a lot of them do don't get
me wrong I'm not saying they don't I'm
saying
if I'm willing to bet if you pulled the
average woman go to Times Square
and walk up to as many people as
possible and say would you want to rule
the world men are probably two to one
gonna say yes women two to one gonna say
no
someone on Twitter it's I'm not saying
it's absolute a lot of women will say
yes for sure no but a lot of these
stories have to come from a place of
knowing and I guarantee you a man wrote
the script or green litter gave notes
like there's an SNL sketch not that they
ever do very well with it but there's
one where it's like a house full of
people and it's like one of the reality
shows and there's lesbians and the whole
joke is the two women are laying in bed
together and they're going like I see
you I know I see you too I see you and I
see you and it's hilarious because if a
guy wrote that it would be like what Doc
Martens they both were construction like
it would be this hacky but it was
actually really funny because it was
written from a place of understanding
who they actually were to make fun of it
so you have this thing that doesn't
actually make sense to any guy and you
probably have these Studio heads going
like yeah she wants to be a boss lady
like we'll do it like that right that's
what all women want and you're not going
to get anything that connects with an
audience so here's the issue how many uh
how many women want to see a movie about
a woman being in charge and how many men
want to see a movie where they're like
the man is not needed and not useful
none
some right some market for it but it's
probably small well yeah here's the
question why are there so many how come
none how come 95 of strip clubs are
women
the girls that work there you mean the
people that work there yeah 95 of strip
clubs are women stripping I would say
testosterone is probably the number one
reason how come it's not 50 50. yeah
these feminists look like girls males
want to go there it's it's interesting
it's like they're not seeking out the
women you know what you know why
fantasizing about impregnating I've seen
women rare movies and those fat ants
sure go to town women on average are not
attracted to submissive men who are
being controlled by someone else
I was reading studies on the disparity
and what they've found is women go to
male strip clubs typically because it's
funny
women women go to female strip clubs
because it's funny man go to female
strip clubs because they're horny
what they said was that women are not
attracted to weak men who are being
dominated by somebody else going into a
big room where the man has to perform
for a group of people who are hooting
and hollering is not typically
attractive to a woman
this is
seeing the creep that can come out in
men who get way to arouse at a strip
club I would imagine is not it's like
the girl from The Office who's like I'll
go I don't mind seeing that but then
she'll never talk to you again right
because she's seen you at your lowest
point
like if you go like if you go to a strip
club a male strip club have you been no
I've never been done but I like so I was
on I've never been to Danny's in Windsor
no I can't say like but the thing is I
have noticed a bunch of names
go to cheetahs and the girls would go
over there and giggle yeah yeah like and
we would be essentially a whorehouse
I've known girls who do that and they're
like haha look how empowered so fun but
like they're not going there for any
reason right they're going there to be
like I'm so forward thinking and edgy
right it's the same thing with like when
you have like bachelorette parties and
they go to drag shows right like at bars
hopefully appropriately age but like
they're going because it's like kind of
something fun and different men go to
strip clubs for an entirely different
reason they don't go just to be like
look at this fun group activity we're
doing like sorry you guys are creepy and
weird guys not by themselves yeah I've
never met a girl who's like going alone
to a all-male strip club or like any of
this is ridiculous you do she's broken
in every way man I don't I don't watch
anymore I feel bad for her I think part
of it is is important to acknowledge
that like men and women
seek different things out of emotional
relationships and even like watching
movies right so so there are reasons
what you'll you'll have this stereotype
of like the movie you go with your
boyfriend to see versus the movie your
girlfriend takes you to see uh I think
the example of this weekend of Barbie
and Oppenheimer right people are talking
about this like in a gendered way uh
what I think is dumb about this this
she's not even thinking about falling in
love like that's just such a lie why are
you stripping women from their emotional
core like women are hardwired to seek
community and relationships and part of
that is finding a life partner and
that's cool and beautiful and if you
want her to be you know CEO of not dwarf
Industries or whatever that's fine but
to be like because she's too good to be
thinking about love that's sort of ugly
towards women right that's saying that
these things that you feel naturally are
thinking something you should be ashamed
of and avoid and that's a weird movie
for a message to send I I do like a
message for a movie to send I do like
that Gal Gadot is the evil queen
because like Gal Gadot looks at Rachel
zegler and she's like I am jealous of
how beautiful she is like you look the
same all right
ugly woman to play that role for well I
think the evil queen was beautiful but
she still was jealous that was part of
her yeah Maleficent or whatever is that
who it was yeah Melissa it's not that
Millicent isn't beautiful it's just that
she's jealous and part of like Snow
White's beauty is like the fact that
she's so kind and and she's sweet and
things like that there's there's a
youthfulness about her that you know
this woman is jealous of and that is
actually a super interesting concept
women should explore that because
jealousy is rampant among women right no
you know what women really did like
though that movie where the uh the dude
kidnaps the woman's dad and then she
gets Stockholm syndrome and marries him
uh Beauty and the Beast ah yeah they do
like that movie and he's not even a good
looking fella what happens see women are
not as visually oriented as men who
kidnaps who in that movie uh the dad
yeah yeah yeah the Beast kidnapped her
kidnaps her dad y'all made a billion
dollars yeah made a billion dollars
beauty is that the live-action one where
is like the Beast doesn't even look that
good fortunately and it's it's literally
a movie about a monster that kid that
like blackmails and extorts someone
saying either live with me or I'm gonna
kidnap your dad and then she falls in
love with him and he has a big Library
she's a big Library like he's got assets
that she's interested in and you know
she's not interested I remember watching
The Animated Beauty and the Beast movie
and I've talked to other girls about
this and when they finally show the
prince after he like stops being the
Beast like you're actually like well
he's kind of disappointing the Beast was
like much more like interesting looking
there is something that women are not
compelled by the way that men are I
think that's the weirdest thing that
Hollywood is trying to sometimes argue
that like ultimately women are just as
visually oriented as men that they were
looking for the same things men they're
not that's why they're different there's
a reason for this so that's okay so I'm
doing a big bear man who talks to Spoons
yeah like dude he's got a castle and he
dresses nicely and he got some books
that's what they're saying on X someone
was asking earlier that um
uh yeah they xed out that um yeah that's
the best one women want a strong male
protective force in their life I don't
know if that's inherent to every woman
but it feels like the movie's trying to
write that out and I'm gonna divert back
to our little Snow White interview right
she's like she's gonna do all these
things her dad told her she could do
we're upholding the patriarchy if
nothing else that's the only winning
winning attribute of this it would have
been it would have been better if it
would have been more feminist if she
said no Dad I'm not gonna do what you
think I should I've Found Someone I love
and care about and I want to be with him
instead the film is the dad being like
you're gonna be a great leader and she's
like sure whatever you say Dad
for my life father I'll follow your
instructions I'm not going to go to
Wellesley and study art or whatever I
always said that was in 80s movies and
stuff like that where the guy was a
little bit of a slouch or whatever but
the girls still loved him
like there wasn't that element where it
was just the typical guy like the girl
made that choice like every Kevin Smith
movie yeah like every Kevin Smith movie
yeah
[Laughter]
that's true I was trying to think of
other ones but more like you know Uncle
Buck you know what's crazy that Gaston's
the good guy but he's the bad guy nah
he's worse he's so nice propaganda he's
also a gay man who's just trying to be
like yeah I want her yeah to come with
me she's a feather in his hat he's not
appealing to her here's the way here's
what is an example of what we might
describe as false masculinity right sure
physically huge but he does not actually
a good companion no no what I'm saying
is you're getting a story from the
beast's perspective because history is
written by the winners so of course
Gaston's is awful dude he's a veteran
that everyone loves clearly like he's
he's built generated esteem within the
community for some reason and they're
just smearing his good name
he tries to save her Beast kidnaps her
dad and then forces her to live with
them she could Stockholm syndrome and
he's like hey guys can we get together
and save this woman or dad and they're
like you're evil you're the bad guy
that's Stockholm syndrome she goes and
lives in a castle where Enchanted things
take care of her she's the force too
I don't know the the teacups come out
and dance she's having like okay time I
will say to be fair that might have just
been a hallucination I mean you don't
know what he was oh yeah
it is also strangely like communistic
that the prince minding his own business
gets a knock at the door and some
witches like give me free stuff and he's
like no and then she's like okay now
I'll curse you yeah I mean it's like
yeah I'm in my house you know I'm
minding my own business and I get cursed
what did I do wrong the Beast you would
get angry that was his like worst fault
like he never beat the hell out of bell
if he did the movie wouldn't have got
made for sure
to be fair I would hope that she would
leave in that situation she's getting
beat up by the beast but like we may
have not seen that part that's true plus
she was largely covered in most of her
body we don't know yeah there's no
ripped clothing or anything he was a
gentleman a beastly gentleman he could
have been punching her in the legs I
just think we're having the candlesticks
it's doomed to fail I don't understand
why we're doing this I also understand
why I have to keep remaking animated
Disney Classics right I have no idea the
dancing Teacups are gonna be good in
this version no that's half the charm
there's also no Angela Lansbury so no
thank you yeah she was lit she carried
the 80s man yeah she did you're telling
me that relationship podcasts are
completely dominated by women but this
wench is not thinking about falling in
love like you're just lying what was it
so I I don't want to say the Aladdin
move which came out in 2019 made a
billion dollars as well so I won't be
surprised if this would make some money
but it's a question of where Sno where a
little mermaid is in in terms of box
office oh yeah I would like to see those
numbers did that do okay I wonder I
people were mad it's like I just don't
care I only care because uh redheads are
a genetic minority on Earth and we just
erased them from a casting position
yeah that's true I have even more
genetically redheaded relatives and they
you know are not being able to see true
redheads on on that's that's the only
thing I care about it looks like it
looks like so I hope it hurt a little
mermaid is a break even film right now
oh my god oh so it actually is
like they were kind of pretending it
would be well I mean these other movies
have had a couple years at the billion
dollar Mark so I mean if they made their
money back you know there you go do you
think with Snow White that the story is
they think it's not going to appeal to
young women because she's kind of
helpless throughout the story like she's
she falls asleep and she's kind of out
of it for half the movie almost I think
they missed the charm because they're
they see this character that's you know
taking care of the dwarves and packing
lunches and like helping them get their
house in order and they feel as though
that makes her seem too domestic and
subservient to these like
mythical male characters and I think
what they miss is the pack the fact that
she is like a service oriented person
who's very Charming there's a lot of joy
you know she's constantly singing I
think they miss the things that make
Snow White have the beauty that the
witch is actually jealous of it's not
just physical Beauty it's like Beauty
and the soul and they scrub that because
they feel like those things make her
instead of too subservient it's weirdos
it did do bad the release uh it is still
one of the highest grossing Memorial Day
opening weekends its projection was 120
to 125 million it hit 118.8 so just shy
of its Target however outside the US it
did not do it that well it fell short of
expectations so it still looks like I'm
assuming with a budget around 200 and
some odd million dollars their marketing
budget was probably around 200 million
as well so it looks like as of right now
they're slightly above break even and
we'll see the thing is movies are all
built upon the previous movie not the
current movie what I mean is Pirates of
the Caribbean 2 did well because Pirates
of the Caribbean one was good and you
know when when the first Pirates movie
came out I did not see it in theaters I
saw it afterwards I was like wow that
was awesome same yeah so when the second
one came out I was like let's go and
then I was like that movie sucks I
agreed and this is where we're at people
might be saying I want to go see a
little mermaid because I liked Aladdin
and Beauty and the Beast and now they
may be walking out going like huh so
we'll see I think I think the snow white
film will probably be a lot worse I
watched that first Aladdin movie
probably 50 times that cartoon Robin
Williams yeah yeah all those Disney
characters are fantastic but part of it
is because and I wish we had our
resident cartoonist here uh the imagery
and cartoon manipulation allow you to do
things that you obviously wouldn't get
to do with live animation my example
here would be the live-action Lion King
which I didn't see but everyone who I
know who saw it was like it just it
seemed weird and kind of creepy it
didn't have this like adorable animal
talking interaction it didn't have the
charm that animated movies have you
can't just make something live action
blue it had its moments they're gonna
put people on AI augmented reality
Disney's gonna make this and you'll be
able to become the Beast like um you'll
be able to experience the woman falling
in love with you you'll be able to rage
you'll be like smashed through the urns
on the wall and you're like ah and you
go through that part of the game and
then Belle arrives and I think do not
hit her and you're like no dude you're
you're you're you're you're under
thinking it
it's going to be predictive full full uh
environmental destruction
totally open realities in Worlds the
story lines are going to be
amorphous there's going to be a general
storyline they want to follow and you
could easily deviate from yeah if you've
played Elder Scrolls I think uh not was
it Oblivion that's for Elder Scrolls
where you'd you'd kill a person in the
game and it would be like this person
was important to the timeline you can
choose to continue but the history is
irreverably damaged or you can go back
and start over you could choose I love
that about those games you could
actually in that game remove a main
character and end the storyline it's
gonna be like that but fully AI so if
you do play as the Beast you could walk
up to Bell and just clock her boom right
in the face and the story breaks It'll
like teach you how to fall how to how to
get a woman and then it can manipulate
you to think like if I say these things
she won't like me if I say these though
she will and it'll be programming young
men yeah I think it's gonna be worse
girl even if you're a guy yeah if you
wanted to be you gotta be like the
difficulty setting this is what's going
to be people are going to go into these
games and they're going to be whatever
whatever they identify as they're gonna
enter you know solo single player
virtual realities where they they just
choose to be what they want to be want
to be Superman you go into Superman
world you never leave but here's what
happens
you will live in the pot and you will
eat the bugs yeah that's gonna happen
you know why because we we right now are
one foot in one foot out of the
traditional reality yes people these
kids they're growing up today are
increasingly growing up in the network
it will be you ubiquitous and normal to
them go back 200 years and tell one of
the founding fathers in our time you
have to register your number with the
government in order to work they'll say
what no no no no no no that can't have
happened here it's a free country of a
constitution no no everybody when you're
born you get your number stamped and you
need that if you want to get access to
jobs
you have your government number
you know it's going to be crazy people
are going to live in pods totally in
isolation they're going to do
rudimentary jobs most most stuff will be
automated they won't care to ever meet
you or interact humans likely will not
talk to each other for the most part
because they're gonna say look please
can I just go back in my pod my my world
needs me they'll you'll get a knock on
the door and it'll be you know an IRS
guy showing up at your house and it'll
be like we need to deduct taxes from
your account that's fine it's fine take
whatever you want I live in the pot I
hate the bugs I don't care I gotta get
back to virtual world
I think you're right but I don't want it
No One's Gonna Force how do we fix it
though no no listen listen
you you will bombs you will no no I know
I'm joking I'm completely you already
know that idea failed but his he was
right about a lot of stuff he was right
about technology destroying the world I
mean it was the way he went about it was
silly so I'll say it so you're gonna
you're gonna get old me come on you're
gonna get old you're gonna die and kids
will grow up and it will be normal and
they will just live their life you gotta
like make the world exciting that's for
sure the world is exciting but people
don't care man you gotta get your the
real world I mean maybe you can talk
about this because you actually have a
kid but I feel like part of it is not
plugging your kids in too early right
like letting your kids develop an
imagination on their own yeah because if
you were just immediately trained to
seek Visual and simulation and like any
sort of creative things comes from a
screen then how much of your brain have
you cultivated to fill in the gaps when
you are not plugged in my kid likes to
play baseball drums all kinds of stuff
before he likes to go online and like he
always but yeah I think which means
he'll like to do other stuff before he
decides it's worth getting the pot way
rather go outside than do and and that's
what I enjoy like I did show movies
earlier on because I love movies and
Cinema older movies too but yeah the
idea of just handing somebody a tablet
and being like there you go that'll
raise you I mean I think that's a huge
problem today I really do that's exactly
why it's gonna I fear that's where it's
going
because these these kids are going to
grow up in that world unless you take
away the technology from your kids now
which I I don't know maybe it's possible
I think a lot of people do and you're
right A lot of people don't and I think
the fact is is too with schools I don't
know I mean our school not as much I
don't know how Public Schools do it but
a lot a huge part of that is taking your
tablet take another thing like you are
learning on all of this stuff So
eventually yeah I mean everything you
are learning and everything that's going
into your head is part of this whole
system that's the value of it is the
data transmission like that you can
learn information so quickly you can
learn how to where to hit the tree with
the ax you learn how sharp in the ax you
can learn where to get an ax but I feel
like part of it is training kids to read
the first 10 sentences of something and
move on to the next thing whereas like
if you handed a kid a book and we're
like read these things and tell me what
you learned it's training the attention
span to last longer and you're still
getting a lot of information yeah
attention spans big shorts make me
nervous internet shorts like Instagram
YouTube they really do like I don't like
putting that up like I even like putting
up like a whole cartoon two and I've
made you know what I mean and but people
don't like it as much but there's a
value to seeing like watching them pour
molten copper into dry ice I'm like okay
it only takes 30 seconds let's see what
happens when the molten copper hits the
dry ice and it's just fascinating to
watch and like if I could have saw that
when I was six I could have seen that
when I was six would it help me learn
but if you saw that and then had to read
an explanation of like what actual
chemical changes are happening you would
actually be better verse like you can
say I saw this video and this is what
happened but if I asked you to explain
why those things are happening what are
the theories behind them you may not be
as prepared to talk about it good idea
you see what I mean like it's not that
technology has to be evil all the time I
just think that there are uh traditional
ways of
consuming information that take longer
so we feel like it's better because it's
coming out us faster but again that's
our desire to have immediate
gratification I think if you watch
something happen like that though
depending on the age over time you can
learn it of why it happened if you're
interested sometimes you can't take in
that information just by reading it I
think the idea of maybe seeing something
like that and then wanting to understand
why it happened is also a benefit
if that makes sense like at least the
way that I always learn like showing a
kid seven different Instagram stories or
whatever stories of like science
projects and then the one that they like
the most you'll investigate that one
right yeah or like kids have questions
questions right so like I could see you
know if your kid is like where's ketchup
come from like pulling out a YouTube
video that's 10 minutes long that gives
like a brief history of ketchup this is
a specific example from my real life you
know can be good but then also on top of
that trying to be like well let's maybe
read about this period of history that
this came from or this region of the
world like trying to show them that you
can expand knowledge that isn't just
like falling down a video hole of like
things that are slightly related it's
very it's a very different uh way of
giving children out I'm you're actually
a parent so you should probably talk
about no I'm not saying I don't think
you're wrong I mean if my son asked for
ketchup came from I'd be like it's a
bottle
I I really wouldn't have any answer for
I feel like tomatoes and well like
that's like full-on like does your kid
want to know what is literally ketchup
made of could you like look that up or
is it like history how did we get
ketchup yeah well it was explain it more
than just show a video to be honest a
man who had traveled to China and they
had katsa and he tried to recreate it
and it was a tomato based vinegar sauce
and he got Cuts up and they were
actually we have ketchup all kinds of
other versions of ketchup too it wasn't
originally just tomato it was America
it's like kind of made it homogenized
tomato oh interesting some guy was like
I'd deep fried a potato and they were
like oh this is crazy how good you know
the potato chip story no a guy was at a
restaurant this is the legend and he
ordered the thinly sliced potatoes with
his meal he got them they were not thin
enough and he complained and said I
wanted thinly sliced potatoes these are
thick and so the chef was like okay and
he cut them thin and gave them back and
the guy was like I said thin so the chef
was like are you okay fine so he cut
them as thin as he could and fried them
so they were chips yeah like I was like
these are amazing these are exactly what
I want and that's the legend of potatoes
yeah this says uh comes from keysop
Ketchup from the Malay word kisap which
meant soy sauce yeah it's a sauce and
like in England there were several
different versions again because it got
picked up and moved around so they
changed it from soy to tomatoes and
again I watched one 10-minute video
YouTube video on this I'm an expert now
uh the reason one of the reasons heinz's
favors is because they switched to the
clear glass bottle before that they were
packaging them in green bottles but they
were like our way of making it makes
them fresher and the color is better
because a lot of ketchup was sort of
more Brown and it was disguised in the
green bottle I love red yeah it's true
it's true isn't it kind of weird that
like ketchup is the meritocratic sauce
of choice yeah it's just like the sauce
I'm just down with it I'm not gonna lie
I love catches it's amazing I get the
good stuff though that has no sugar yeah
the organic yeah just straight up yeah I
get the trash yeah the corn syrup stuff
I eat like a raccoon it was interesting
diet it kind of ingest that you watched
a a 10 minute video and now you're an
expert because you kind of but I'm not
calm when you gain you're starting to
gain expertise just from 10 minutes so
like I said
because if you watch 80 10 minute videos
you're not going to be an expert in all
80 like if you watch one of them and you
over and over and you pay attention to
it but watching the videos with my
younger sisters who asked me where did
ketchup come from how did we get it uh
we got to this part and I was like oh we
could go to the Heinz Ketchup Museum and
like learn some more about this if you
wanted to like there are lots of ways to
take information that aren't just like
online right you can you can do a skit
where it's like you got the keto diet
you got carnivore you got vegan and you
have the raccoon diet yeah where you're
like you walk into a restaurant and grab
someone's half eaten sandwich
you're like see it's whatever is left so
it's it's something you know what I mean
and finish someone's milkshake and you
can explain the reason it's better is
that in the average American diet people
tend to have a routine and they'll eat
many of the same things this means a
restricted amount of vitamins they're
actually getting in their diet with the
raccoon diet you get a plethora of
different foods thus getting all the
vitamins you need yes and you get a
little bit of exercise because people
will try to get their food back while
you hiss at them and run
them lifestyle they'll get like dark
Rings under his eyes yeah yeah slowly
you look like a burglar every time you
grab someone's food that's good you get
the crap kicked out if you go to Waffle
House with your raccoon
all right let's read let's read super
chats if you haven't already which
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member so you can
watch our uncensored members only show
which will be live at about 10 pm and
you as members can even ask questions of
us and our guest just sign up at the 25
per month level or if you've been a
member for at least six months it's a
screening process you then submit
questions we choose four or five every
night that'll be up at 10. over at
timcast.com but uh let's uh let's read
some super chats I didn't mention some
of these already so let's read uh some
more
Elaine Bennett says castbrew doesn't
ship to Canada haramf I do believe
international shipping is in the works
there's like something we have to do
and we may have new products tomorrow
we may uh the latest update I got is it
looks like we may have the current cups
the decaf Blends uh I don't think we're
having espresso roast just yet but the
K-Cups it's big and that may be tomorrow
we have sleepy Joe and unwoke our decaf
Blends will be available at uh
casper.com and we're going to be
separating right now all of the Blends
if you click it you choose ground or
whole but we keep getting emails from
people who are like how come you don't
offer whole bean because the graphic
says ground on it so we're just going to
double it up so it's gonna say ground
and hole and that way people can just
click it uh but I'm excited for that so
question on the way on the K-Cup is it
they're called K-Cups for legal purposes
I have no idea I don't know how that
works because Keurig was a company that
I think they got invented for and then
the cups just became prolific it's a
colloquial term
makeup that's all everyone says let's
grab some more Super chats Raymond g
Stanley Jr says and he's back Tim were
you chomping at the bit to make content
after a week Away Hannah Claire held
down the fort last week Sheamus well
oh Sheamus uh we're glad he was here uh
I was sitting in a recliner for you know
like eight hours a day staring at
Dolphins uh that's for the most part it
was cool the The View was just the the
ocean and you can see the border and
there were Dolphins and the funniest
thing that happened was um and with no
disrespect to the wonderful nurse and
people there there was a seal okay and
the seal was by itself
and the Dolphins were bothering that
seal but do you guys not to say bother
in Spanish no no do you want to look it
up real quick Hector no let's just uh
what's happening I think so what is it I
appreciate it what is it La Molestia
yeah let me say that again La Molestia
oh yeah right just like do not disturb
so what happened was
that's right people are saying molestar
so uh the the kind woman who worked
there whose second language was English
said the Dolphins keep molesting the
seal and we just are laughing and she's
like look look they're molesting the
seal and we're like yeah and I'm just
like I know what it means in Spanish I'm
not gonna be mean but it was funny the
Dolphins were just swimming around the
ceiling bothering it they weren't doing
anything untoward beyond that but it was
fun so glad to be back I've seen
dolphins do some uh crazy stuff with
they were jumping that's awesome yeah
wow and then there are these birds that
go up in the air and then dive down
super cool what were they I don't know
what they're called I don't know I would
I don't know if they were it was cool
they go up and they're in San Diego too
and then they just you see them dive
boom and into the water and then come
out with a fish they're like Pelicans
the herrings yeah I don't do their
Pelicans they may be heroes no no
seagulls aren't smooth like that those
those
are a lot of sea lions in San Diego
though everybody who lives there now is
like it's a normal thing yeah we're in
California right yeah and there was and
there was like a seal laying on the
beach in the morning and people came
over and started like yelling at it and
then it ran the water and then the
Dolphins yeah
Hermosa Beach that was always weird oh
yeah and in Florida too in Florida in
the swamps and stuff yeah
yes Eagles are on the uh raccoon diet
yeah they are they're trying they're air
raccoons will be one might say that's
why you feed them Alka-Seltzer watch
them die you ever see those pictures or
video of them like swooping down and
taking out ice cream with them on their
way out yeah that's crazy no I would
feed seagulls when I was a kid but you
can't would you feed them Alka-Seltzer
yeah whatever you had with you okay all
right let's read some more Fire Burns
people says Tim this morning you talked
about customer service being a robot the
trick to getting by all the robots is to
speak complete gibberish regardless
until it forwards you to a real person
incorrect good sir I am going to teach
you all a powerful hack have you ever
been dealing with customer service and
it's a robot you bet and when you speak
and say hi I'm having a problem with my
with my phone service it'll go okay let
me see if I can help you you said your
car service no my phone service I'm
sorry let me try again there's one
simple thing you have to say
to get it to instantly transfer you to a
human and you know what that one simple
thing is what operator you really I
am not joking okay you already swore
earlier on so yeah let's make this one
we're already there uh I have learned in
most instances what I would first do is
a human being and it would go you want
to talk to a representative but I can
help why don't you try asking me the
question human being I'm sorry I didn't
get that I'm like I learned a long time
ago that as soon as you say you it
goes I'm transferring you now is it at
the tone that you said if you go if you
say it real nice like you will it
be like it doesn't know the tone you can
just literally be like hello you
and it goes transferring call wow just
instantly no problem so I was on the
phone with United and the first time I
saw United this is crazy United
transferred us from our first class
flight from Vegas to DC to coach Den so
it was Vegas Houston DC they Tran they
abruptly without telling us moved us to
a different flight so we went uh Vegas
Denver DC coach in the back of the plane
I'm like we paid for this give us a
refund at least they were like I'm sorry
we can't help you there were no
employees so we get to the airport our
tickets are gone they don't the app
doesn't have them anymore this is the
crazy thing about not having your ticket
printed too it's like the app just gone
I'm like how am I getting in
go go to the terminal no employees
anywhere not not a single agent so I
call the customer service line
robot and I say human being over and
over again it would not do it finalized
went you and it was like
transferring your call instantly sent me
to a woman who was in South Africa and
she had no idea what was going on said
sir your original flight to Houston to
DC is still here listed as available
first class I don't understand what
you're talking about and I'm like I have
an email saying you moved me to a
different flight coach and there she was
like I can put you back I guess there
was a delay I guess and because of the
delay they just moved without asking us
even though the delay there was still
another flight we could have uh caught
then finally when an employee shut up
they snapped at us and yelled at us and
said I can't help you go away so I'm
just like this is this is this is crazy
the funniest thing that happened though
you're gonna love it I'm standing at the
counter waiting and a woman looks at a
guy and she goes I'm sorry sir we'll get
your bag on the plane but the computers
are down and I just thought it was
absolutely hilarious that there is an
issue a man has a bag in front of him
the bag should be on the plane with him
but the computers are down so they can't
do it why only the computer had the
authority to allow the bag to go on the
plane
so the human being staring at the bag
couldn't do it I'm like that's the
future you're going to require some
ridiculously rudimentary task and the
computer will say sorry you'll be at a
convenience store you'll have a bottle
of Pepsi in your hand and a dollar in
your other and I'll say ah I'm sorry man
computers are down I can't sell you that
that Pepsi and you'll be like can I
leave the dollar here with you no I'll
get in trouble I can't do it I can't
trade with you unless the mark of the
beast yep that's exactly what I was
thinking I had one amazing thing with
United now that you've mentioned that
Airline was I was going to get on they
go actually we have a flight that's an
hour sooner to Greenville and I was like
oh that's great so I got on the flight
and I flew and I'm supposed to go to
Greenville South Carolina
so I landed in Greenville North Carolina
so when I got there to be picked up it's
like we're at the airport I'm like I'm
at the airport I don't know what's going
I don't know I'm right here for real for
real they put you on a different to a
different state
huh yeah wow I didn't know though United
did that I assumed they were like you
know aware so I just took their word for
it nobody corrected me so when I got
there finally they're like oh you're in
a different state I'm like of course why
wouldn't I be
I I wanna I wanna stress this too I will
never fly United again it is you know
that was the day I stopped Deltas people
keep telling me Delta it was 3 A.M our
flight was at six we wake up at 3 30. we
get to the airport like four something
boarding time was 5 20. right so I
already have the app with the tickets on
it right when we get to security I look
at the app and it says C agent and it
said Denver instead of Houston and I'm
like what just happened how did I I
didn't buy a ticket to Denver so you
don't you don't need gang you don't need
tickets to get in the airport anymore
which is crazy I think you legally do
whatever but they were like it's it said
Ticket available but no seat assignment
or anything like that and the guy was
like that's fine you don't need to just
come on in and I I went in went to
security and they they don't check for
that anymore and then went to the
terminal no employees anywhere boarding
was in 20 minutes and I'm like what is
going on
it's crazy from uh Colorado on the way
back last weekend I guess I flew United
and my flight got delayed going into
Chicago and I got off the plane they're
like you have nine minutes your plane is
leaving in in 10 minutes so I ran the
hardest I'd run in 17 years literally in
17 years I ran flailing through the
airport and I was coughing up mucus
thanks United I made my flight though
somehow but really it was crazy I ran so
hard like Red Zone hard it was dude I
hate that and they're like oh you're
lucky you made it you're like really
it's your fault yeah luck had nothing to
do with it my friends not at that time I
pushed myself yeah I can't stand it and
I thought about dudes in the military
like running with rucksacks for their
life yeah and the amount of respect I
gained for people that have gone through
that man what the oh dude I could never
that's why yeah I respect veterans the
raccoon diet won't support no no no I
can barely get away from the people who
want their sandwich back
let's read some more Super chants
definitely not a fed says my best friend
was a private Chef to a billionaire
would spend weekends at a time at their
estate was like family with them when he
quit the billionaire cried and said that
he felt like it was losing a family
member yeah you know I I understand that
for sure yeah yeah maybe if someone's in
your home all the time yeah making the
food you're consuming so like their
Spirit becomes part of you making love
to you on Tuesdays
your eyes
Sammy Scott says I tried to swim across
a river I'm unfit I used all my energy
about halfway went back in an empty tank
got 10 feet from the shore and literally
couldn't move just started sinking my
mate saved me man crazy well glad to
hear you're all right were you doing the
thing where you you go forward and you
go on your back and then go back and
stuff like that
that's what you're supposed to do yeah
you know alternating all your muscles
and you float and then you go on your
back and backstroke or whatever then
once you get tired you flip over and use
different muscles oh I didn't know that
I've always been a swimmer though
nice well don't look at me I'm not an
expert swimmer all like all I know is
that when I go in the pool I just go
like this and I just don't sink yeah but
that's because you're Tim pool I mean
yeah
yes when um I know during character
creation they were like if you use the
secret name you get plus one yeah
you get the swimming skill based on your
name you can beat any woman in an
olympic race
yes
we will grab some super chats let's see
where we're at what is this
our wg5 says my mom majored in homack at
Cal Poly San Luis Obispo San Luis Obispo
she has a ba in being a mom whoa it's
crazy that and uh they're like degrees
you could get in home X stuff wow yeah
see this is the thing
for human beings
everybody wants social acceptance to
varying degrees
so guys get it through doing guy things
and women get it through get it through
women things but now all media and all
culture is saying be a guy
it used to be that you're like I have a
degree in home economics I'm the expert
and you would be praised and feel good
for that accomplishment so women were
like I have something to strive toward
this is a good thing and people were
impressed by it and then one day they're
like nah you should be working in an
office just the power of a woman man at
home to take care of me like I never
really have appreciated it until this
point in my life and I don't have kids
yet I imagine when the kids are in the
picture and the woman is taking care of
them it's like the most amazing but like
just to be able to help me with with
diet and focus and motivation like that
you cannot buy that I also think we used
to think of running home like
essentially running a small business
with these crazy customer slash
employees that don't really speak
English I hate children right like yeah
there was like one of the things that
I've read about homemak is like if you
suddenly own a home right and we all
theoretically go through stages we have
to learn how to like evaluate appliances
how do you price home repair how do you
make nutritious food especially in the
day and age when you didn't have as much
nutrition information printed on the
package like how do you sew your own
clothes like all of these things that we
had to do at one point were and she was
very increased you still have to do they
were very serious things that needed
management so if you're a man out there
earning money great for you someone has
to keep the business running at the
house and that typically Falls home and
like it's more than just the emotional
sport that's a huge part of it but there
was a time when we respected that the
family was a unit that needed
maintenance and care and that was
typically something women took care of
and because we had these institutions to
support them it showed up showed that
this was something we wanted as a
society when we took those away it was
like saying that's not important you
shouldn't do it but everyone in this
room has a household that needs to be
kept up it's crazy to me that we threw
that out yeah here's a good one Bailey
and says Elon needs to put in a local
tab that shows the people in your city
and state are talking about on top of
all other tabs agree that's fantastic
that's a great idea
yeah local and you'll see just people
around you posting stuff that's really
for Elon somebody tell us if you're
watching this and you know and mention
that to him because it's a really really
good idea Bailey and Shout out I would
love to use that right now because it's
really important when I was in New York
it was easy when there was something
going on we heard a loud noise I would
search like New York bang and then you'd
see everyone posting about it you can do
that but it's not as easy if you're in a
rural area or smaller town imagine if
you you heard a big explosion or
something you could pull up your app or
you like the storm was coming in you
open up Twitter you press the magnifying
glass there's for you there's trending
and there's local could you just use
like your Town's like name and state as
a hashtag to get out information that
way but people don't do that but if they
did do that that would be one way sure
but so so right until Elon comes through
with his change perhaps for this Geo
track people device people could do that
but it's an issue of do people know how
and if you create a tab in the search
section that says local and it just
shows you people in proximity talking
about what they talk about publicly
that's that's a that's a brilliant or if
you could change the setting in the
local tab to any zip code something like
where you could right because you'll be
traveling and stuff that would be a
great idea because like you could even
do like Marketplace like Facebook does
like Craigslist is dead I don't know if
you guys have used Craigslist recently
but it's it's no one uses just to murder
everyone uses Facebook Marketplace and
Twitter could do that with locals if
they already have the Geo kind of
fencing up with uh local tweets you know
you get to start selling products and
Facebook Marketplace sometimes you get a
subsidized shipping uh it like costs
less to if you buy something off
Facebook Marketplace and ship it then if
you just like ship to someone directly
Let's uh jump into the Super Chat we
have self-made women saying Tim at all I
know know where you stand on this but
I'm wired to desire neuralink I need
that chip in my head experiencing
transhuman dysphoria how can I get
norelink's attention
The Leaky spigot I have no idea
but if you'd like to volunteer perhaps
you can go on Twitter tweet Elon Musk
and say you volunteer for the Chip
he needs the thing how did he phrase
that do you still have that tweet I need
he rhymed something in the very
beginning I uh experiencing transhuman
dysphoria it was like the very first
thing he typed
uh self-made woman says Tim at all I
know where you stand on this but I'm
wired to desire to desire yeah you're
wired how do you get the attention you
want it in your head sooner than later
just be patient I'm telling you people
will beg for it they will beg for it you
know why the chip yes no thank you it's
not just going to be in cells who want
girlfriends it's going to be a dad who
lost his son it's going to be a mom who
a wife who lost her husband it is going
to be a mother who's who's uh whose son
was who died in the war and in that
reality they can take every social media
post that they ever made and they will
create the predictive text version of
your loved one that you lost and they
will say to you join us get the chip and
talk to Nana again talk to Jimmy again
and people are gonna say I will give you
anything the pain of knowing the person
who I love yeah some people will but no
no no no I'm not saying I'm not saying
you're wrong either I just can't imagine
being so disconnected from the reality
of life I mean that's part of life is
the beauty of that you knew somebody not
I was an AI version of I would think
like if you dip off the AI at the end of
the day or whatever you turn the machine
off that it would cause visceral
emotional damn that look in your gut
like hatred like the most but that's
what I mean addicted to it right like
you never want to leave the AI and then
you atrophy and die you can't maintain
any real life social connections I think
reliving that pain though in such a uh
uh God extreme way that would almost
cause suicide or some sort of reaction
that you couldn't even control I mean
that could be so dangerous I I there are
a lot of people who are going to be like
no how dare you of course but I'm
telling you man I'm willing to bet that
the average person will just be like
don't judge me they're also they'll do
it in secret they'll they'll they'll say
oh you know I got it for my health I can
check my health and then they'll go home
and it's not just that that's there's
shame stuff in emotional breakdowns
people not wanting to know how messed up
they are over the loss of a loved one or
a breakup who knows what it is but then
there's going to be a lot of dudes doing
really messed up stuff
I mean let's be real we can we can talk
about the messed up stuff dudes are
gonna do with Virtual Worlds they can
create women will do a different kind of
messed up thing they will have their
version of Twisted demented porn like 50
Shades of Gray and they're gonna plug
their brains in in two seconds or it's
gonna be weird emotional stuff like if
they go through an intense breakup right
and in the real world they meet someone
else they get married to a family but
secretly they're still with that other
person in this virtual world like can
you imagine male or female that level of
emotional betrayal if one day you found
out that like the person you love more
than anyone else in the world is
actually keeping alive a relationship
it's it's beyond that they're not done
yeah additional love for though I mean
is that do we understand the human brain
enough to actually play with that to
make a predictive text model I think is
easy but it's not it's it's it's not
just about a lost loved one or a lost
relationship it's going to be some dude
who's like man you know the waitress is
so pretty I'd love to date her I'll date
her in virtual reality and never talk to
her in real life and you don't know
anything about her and you form her to
be whatever you want no because Oliver
tweets and Facebooks are public you just
tell the app to use that to make the
person that stuff is curated right like
you don't put the worst parts of your
life online so you can never really know
someone but they don't want it but that
means that you wouldn't have a true
emotional connection you'd have a but
that's that's that's that's that's a
point I totally agree with you nobody
wants that that's so that takes away
from like an invasion of privacy because
they've put it out there in the public
they can create that person you can
Google something you can Google search
it the machine can crawl and take all
that text and compile a AI version of
the person at least they're public
Persona there will be more um benevolent
people that'll use it but what will
happen is they'll be really rich and
they'll be like I just don't have time I
can't buy time but I can buy the apps to
download Spanish French Russian Italian
I can learn these things rapidly by
coding my brain with my money so all
these rich people that didn't have time
to do all these things will be able to
do them in virtual reality really quick
I just I disagree and that when it comes
to only when it comes to language
everything else yes I agree on but
language specifically the chip will just
translate for you oh interesting so it's
kind of like short circuit you don't
need the data in your brain if someone
says it you'll just instantly it'll the
chip will do the work for you if the
power's on you let's uh let's read this
one from Captain Sunshine it says Tim I
finally started working out again and
quit drinking started taking supplements
to improve my health thanks to your
podcast I've seen the light and decided
to own the libs by being healthy who
knew you guys were a health podcast well
uh We've recently learned about the
raccoon diet another way to improve your
health it's a great way to do it yeah uh
no glad to hear it um a lot of reps
involved yeah there are a lot of reps
cut not the sugars no sugar oh yeah
working out yeah elimination diets are
great when you when you figure out the
things that weren't working it almost
doesn't matter what you're eating I mean
it obviously matters but as long as
you're doing something healthy you just
cut out the ones that are really nasty
with the rancune diet you just a lot of
people don't order dessert
so really that's kind of the benefit is
you're not going to get a lot of dessert
is it uh there's a lot of diplomacy
involved yeah yeah quite a bit Peter
brunquel says you always bring up
furries in your videos like it's a weird
thing I'm offended we're infinitely
worse
okay
thank you for the warning so that's a
real furry not another kid yeah so
that's one who dresses yeah powder pz
says the Beast saved Belle from a pack
of wolves Fair Point oh fair point he
does he did no he did he the the dad
goes he's like he was trespassing so I'm
locking him in the dungeon should I let
him go and he's like only if you stay
how do we know it was in his pack
exactly oh like they faked it was like
yeah
you're Assuming he's a wolf though he's
just a non-descript beast yeah but they
don't know that they're wolves the
wolves are like look we just filed look
we found the way he smells yeah they
just think he's wolf
Thomas side bottom says Ian if you can
commit to gaining 20 pounds of muscle I
can commit to losing 20 pounds of fat
you have motivated me that's based uh
that would that would include me gaining
about 50 pounds or 60 pounds I think
because when I'm what I'm learning is
the weight I gain is not all muscle it's
a lot of fat and water on top of it so
20 pounds of muscle how much would that
be 40 pounds total I'm up five pounds
four pounds that was down before we got
started the goal for the music video
isn't to get Ian like super ripped so
you see bulging muscles it's to get him
just like I guess the idea is we want to
see someone get emaciated so a
combination of fat and muscle but not
obesity you know what I mean yeah more
healthy too fat because I considered
like steroids am I trying to do
something Optical for the movie and like
I would like it to look good but I think
the most important thing is I'm actually
healthy yeah yeah you don't want
steroids maybe increase shake up on some
of the muscles that was like ah now but
it's like no that's Cinema it's okay
because it's not not the guy in the film
in the video is not some super athlete
who's like all ripped and flexing his
muscles it's a regular guy and in the
end you know so you you're always saying
that he like dehydrated and didn't eat
so he could get way down for the final
scenes great my mood was out of control
I didn't even know my mood was was bad
but it was bad one of those things I was
telling you guys that before it's such a
weird place to be mentally
but uh it's gonna it's gonna take a long
time to do but it's gonna be really
awesome that's what they call method
acting when you actually let your body
get to the point where it's supposed to
be for the roll instead of Faking It
inspector tasty says had my morning cup
of rise with Roberto Jr and remember
this crazy dream I had where Tim cast
was shimcast then briefly shimcast was
brimcast absolute Madness hi Ian hi brim
would you uh what'd you think of last
week's shimcast day to day I thought it
was so fun I mean you know I'm grateful
to do the show with with all of you but
uh
I think the thing is like when you work
in this environment there are people
that I see you know I'll see when I'm
getting coffee I talk to Sheamus
regularly and uh it's fun to feel like
we are able to still offer a nice
product and Tim is able to take a break
and you know uh we don't just suddenly
fall through rails it was definitely a
a marathon for us though yeah I felt the
the Train the train was rocking yeah I
think what'd you think that was great
yeah Vivek ramaswamy is one of my
favorite humans on Earth yeah we had two
presidential candidates on last week it
was sort of crazy really the vacant
we're Elder oh that's right yeah it was
Friday and so man you know what a crazy
job it's so crazy I talked to this Irish
guy gets to talk to Ian Sheamus made a
lot of funny jokes that was awesome we
got to bully Sheamus about his
transitions I mean really just family
memories were made I I'm bummed I missed
it but man for months I've been having
range of motion issues in my leg and
strength issues at a certain at a
certain degree at a certain range and uh
it just like the last Skate Session was
like every time I jumped I got punched
how was it today almost no pain at all
it's great like a week later and so the
doctor said take it easy still exercise
so I skated very lightly mostly just did
spins no flips because you know keeping
it lower to the ground and everything
but had a good session and almost no
pain at all and it's
it's awful week yet are you nervous on
it now or do you still do you feel more
comfortable and confident I felt better
than I've ever felt in a long time
Skating it was it was crazy like
reflexes everything felt perfect it was
crazy that's what people say about the
either p with PRP plasma or stem cells
that it's like you feel better than you
did before you got oh yeah it's like
fixing everything you know and even
improving it sometimes uh I'm gonna see
how I skate on Wednesday but uh General
Improvement and the crazy thing like it
I think it's crazy crazy crazy
I I had trouble putting a sock on I
could lift my right leg and put on my
sock I could not lift my left leg I'd
have to sit down and pull my leg over my
other leg to put my socks on mine's both
legs
after getting this within a few days
range of motion was coming back and I
just I'm like I can't believe this oh
it's like it's like hard to believe yeah
there's this short amount of time that
it changes that you know how bucko's
been feeling yeah no joke he's gonna get
more stem cells next week I think yeah
so I'm glad to hear it hey and Vivek
wants to come back Vivek Vivek wants to
come back now you're back in town oh
yeah yeah I was I was so bummed because
I'm a big fan and uh we might even do
some Big Show I don't want to say too
much but we're planning some stuff all
right let's grab but one more Super Chat
right here
let's see what do we have I thought I
had one pulled up
reggae Vibe says there's a movie called
2047 where 70 of the world is plugged
full time into virtual reality and
assassin is hired to kill terrorists
that want to unplug everyone in the end
the on the unplugged people killed them
yikes
all right uh what do we got here
no soup for Noel says this is John Doyle
level anti-beast misinformation the
Beast never suggested Bell stay as his
prisoner Bell offered to stay all right
all right okay we gotta watch this movie
again all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com go to timcast
click join us because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
in a few minutes you don't want to miss
it it's going to be spicy and y'all as
members can even call in and ask
questions you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast Dave do you want
to shout anything out uh yes check out
normal world at sunblaze or youtube.com
at the at sign normal world uh and go
ahead and subscribe uh we have shows
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday at 10 pm
Eastern check us out right on
I'm Hannah Claire brimlaw I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should go to
teamcast.com and click on the read tab
you can see all the work from uh Adrian
Norman Chris Bertman Oliver journalists
they do fantastic stuff you should
definitely 100 follow at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram once again it's
the best if you want to follow me
personally you can find me on Instagram
at hannahclared.b or on Twitter at HC
bromelo thank you so much I am Ian cross
some follow me at Ian Crossland on any
and all of the social networks for the
most part and I asked you out earlier
Dave uh your ex profile anyone that's
going to follow Dave came out is Landau
Dave yes thank you for Xing that out for
me you got it I hate this power to the X
dude appreciate the ZD Exxon Z yeah and
you guys can follow or you can X me at
x.com right is it my daughter right
don't do this I think Twitter is
redirecting to exercise Kellen PDL
that's where I X my favorite thoughts
and you know funny ideas
we'll see you all over at timcast.com in
about a minute or so thanks for hanging
out